Oh my God, we made it.
We made it.
I thought we were going to be late, but here we are.
I didn't have a chance to stop and potty.
Oh, you didn't potty yet?
Maybe we could potty today.
You want to call this pottying?
Yeah.
天哪，我们终于到了。我们到了。我以为我们要迟到了，但我们还是到了。我没机会停下来上个厕所。哦，你还没上厕所吗？也许我们今天可以上个厕所。你想把这叫作上厕所吗？是啊。
You made us run in here for that.
Yeah, we can call it pottying.
We're going to potty.
Oh, man. Welcome to Smartless.
Don't you think we should go on another trip?
I do.
Why don't we?
We always talk about it.
你为了这个让我们跑进来。是啊，我们可以叫它上厕所。我们要去上厕所了。天哪。欢迎来到Smartless。你不觉得我们应该再去旅行一次吗？我觉得应该。为什么不呢？我们总是谈论这件事。
By the way, do you guys like doing it?
I just did a bunch of laundry.
I like, you know what, Scottie and I were talking about this.
Hold on, I need a neck brace.
A couple things, wait a second.
What do you, why are you looking at over your shirt?
The listener's going to think that we've made a weird edit.
Because I just finished, no, no, no, I just finished a ton of laundry.
顺便问一下，你们喜欢做家务吗？我刚洗了一大堆衣服。我喜欢，你知道吗，斯科蒂和我正在谈论这个。等等，我需要一个颈托。有几件事，等一下。你，你为什么在看你的衬衫上面？听众会以为我们做了一个奇怪的剪辑。因为我刚洗完，不，不，不，我刚洗完一大堆衣服。
And I don't usually like folding laundry, but I like folding towels.
I like folding towels because it's like OCD.
So you guys, are you trying to tell us that you do laundry when you're back home in L.A.?
No, sir.
I tell you what, you're a fascinating dinner date.
Tell us more of them.
The folding of the towels, man.
Do you guys, you know what I mean, though?
我通常不喜欢叠衣服，但我喜欢叠毛巾。我喜欢叠毛巾，因为这就像强迫症。所以你们，你们是想告诉我们，你们回到洛杉矶家里时会洗衣服吗？不，先生。我跟你说，你是个迷人的晚餐约会对象。多给我们讲讲。叠毛巾的事，伙计。你们，你知道我的意思吧？
I will tell you that, you know, my...
Did you guys have a lot of discipline growing up as far as, like, having chores and learning how to do everything?
Yeah.
That, like, I know how to wash windows without streaks.
I know how to fold laundry.
I know how to load a dishwasher.
Yeah, I didn't do that.
I know how to sweep in a way that you're not resweeping certain areas.
我会告诉你，你知道，我的……你们小时候有很多纪律吗？比如，做家务和学习如何做每件事？是的。比如，我知道怎么擦窗户才不会留下痕迹。我知道怎么叠衣服。我知道怎么装洗碗机。是的，我没做过那些。我知道怎么扫地，这样你就不会重复扫某些区域了。
Like, my dad taught me how to do everything.
Right.
Yeah, same.
Like before I could like push back and say, I don't want to learn.
I have not done that with my kids.
I mean, they get by.
But like I did.
I just.
比如，我爸爸教我怎么做每件事。对。是的，我也是。在我能反抗说“我不想学”之前。我没有对我自己的孩子这样做。我是说，他们能应付。但我做到了。我只是。
No, but your kids are very responsible.
Yeah, no, they're incredible.
I love them to death.
And they're, they do great.
But I have, I've, I wasn't diligent about like teaching them how to do the things that you're going to need to do the rest of your life.
Like folding a towel, how to do it properly.
Yeah, I remember my mom teaching me how to do that.
Making a bed.
不，但你的孩子非常负责任。是的，不，他们太棒了。我爱死他们了。他们做得很好。但我，我，我没有勤奋地教他们如何做你余生都需要做的事情。比如叠毛巾，如何正确地叠。是的，我记得我妈妈教我怎么做。铺床。
Yeah, we had to because we didn't have any money.
You know that whole story.
And we didn't have a washer and dryer.
It always broke down.
So me and my mom took garbage bags of clothes
and put them in the car and drove to the laundromat.
And I was the only kid that did that.
Wow.
是的，我们必须这样做，因为我们没钱。你知道那个完整的故事。我们没有洗衣机和烘干机。它总是坏掉。所以我和我妈妈拿着装满衣服的垃圾袋，把它们放进车里，开车去自助洗衣店。我是唯一一个那样做的孩子。哇。
Yeah.
Out of the five kids, by the way, they're all listening.
Yeah, we're going to argue about that later.
I started last night getting ahead of the snow outside of my stoop here.
and so I was out every couple hours.
And you knew how to shovel.
Yeah, of course, because it did bring me back
and made me feel like it was a young Canadian.
是的。顺便说一下，五个孩子里，他们都在听。是的，我们稍后再争论那个。我昨晚开始清理我门廊外的积雪。所以我每隔几个小时就出去一次。而且你知道怎么铲雪。是的，当然，因为它确实让我回想起了过去，让我感觉自己像个年轻的加拿大人。
It's the best, right? Yeah, I love it.
So good.
Jay, what about you getting behind the snow?
You know, like, so I would, that's a Coke joke.
It's a Coke joke?
Early or in minute eight?
I know, sorry.
J.B., do you want to...
这是最好的，对吧？是的，我喜欢。太棒了。杰伊，你清理积雪怎么样？你知道，所以我会，那是个可乐笑话。是个可乐笑话？在第八分钟？我知道，抱歉。J.B.，你想……
But, wait, wait, wait, wait, so there's something
that my dad never did teach me
because by the time we left the snow, I was four.
So I didn't have to shovel it.
So I would struggle with snow.
There's probably a real, you need a pair to teach you.
Albo grease.
You don't start at the bottom, right?
但是，等等，等等，等等，等等，有些我爸爸从来没教过我的事，因为当我们离开雪地时，我才四岁。所以我不需要铲雪。所以我会在雪地里挣扎。可能真的需要一个人教你。阿尔伯润滑油。你不能从底部开始，对吧？
You don't dig that shovel all the way to the bottom and try to lift it up.
You got to start taking off the top, right?
Well, it depends on how much snow you go, yeah, yeah, yeah.
But that's why also, like, if you go out and you get it early enough,
like I did it a couple times last night, so that by this morning was it too insane.
You know that night?
Yeah, I used to do that.
What do you think my dad taught me?
你不能把铲子一直插到底部然后试图把它抬起来。你得从顶部开始清理，对吧？嗯，这取决于你有多少雪，是啊，是啊，是啊。但这也是为什么，如果你出去得足够早，就像我昨晚做了几次，这样到今天早上就不会太疯狂了。你知道那天晚上吗？是的，我过去常那样做。你觉得我爸爸教了我什么？
Uh-oh.
Wait, can I come back to this?
Because I'd love to fill out a joke list of 10 to 20.
Yeah, I mean.
And then I'd like to, you know, rank them and really just give you the right week.
I think ultimately how to lower expectations, I guess, in people, in people.
Keep your expectations super low.
Also, how to keep your emotional knees bent, you know, always ready for disappointment.
噢。等等，我可以回到这个话题吗？因为我很想填一份10到20个的笑话清单。是的，我是说。然后我想，你知道，给它们排名，真的给你正确的一周。我想最终是如何降低期望，我想，在人身上，在人身上。保持你的期望值极低。还有，如何保持你的情感膝盖弯曲，你知道，随时准备迎接失望。
Yeah.
Right.
Emotionally bend from the knees, I guess.
Yeah.
Uh-huh.
in a ready position.
Yes, and now look at me.
Yeah.
是的。对。情感上从膝盖弯曲，我想。是的。嗯哼。处于准备状态。是的，现在看看我。是的。
Anyway.
Yeah, you're doing great.
I will say, no.
You know, Shawnee, for all the joking that we do about it, something like that,
you're one of the most caring, thoughtful people I have ever had in my life.
That's a true story.
You really, really, I was saying it to somebody the other day.
Incredible.
总之。是的，你做得很好。我会说，不。你知道，肖尼，尽管我们对此开了很多玩笑，但像那样的事情，你是我一生中遇到过的最关心、最体贴的人之一。这是个真实的故事。你真的，真的，我前几天还在跟别人说。不可思议。
I was saying, I was saying, Sean is the first guy.
Anything's going on in your life.
Something's happened.
He's the first person to check in, send you something, help.
Like he's, thank you.
Sean, you are a perfect example of nature versus nurture.
So there's no even question about the nurture part because we all know the story.
Your father had something to do in some other place aside from staying with you.
我说，我说，肖恩是第一个人。你的生活中发生了什么事。发生了什么。他是第一个关心、给你发东西、提供帮助的人。就像他是，谢谢。肖恩，你是先天与后天影响的完美例子。所以关于后天影响的部分甚至没有疑问，因为我们都知道那个故事。你父亲在别的地方还有别的事要做，而不是和你待在一起。
And you have been able to become this incredible person.
Yes, your mother was incredible to you as well.
But you have, you have natured yourself all the way to the incredible Sean Hayes.
That's very nice.
I natured myself.
That's a new verb.
There's a few things in there that I really enjoyed your father.
It had something else to do elsewhere.
而你已经能够成为这个不可思议的人。是的，你母亲对你也很不可思议。但你，你已经把自己培养成了不可思议的肖恩·海耶斯。那太好了。我培养了我自己。那是个新动词。里面有几件事我真的很喜欢你父亲。他在别处还有别的事要做。
He was late for something.
It natured yourself.
I would accept that compliment as I'm trying to learn as I get older, so thank you for that.
And I will return it to both of you.
I think we all come from backgrounds that challenged us to become better people.
Yeah, amen.
Yeah.
Which tease up our guest perfectly.
他迟到了。它培养了你自己。我会接受那个赞美，因为我随着年龄的增长正在努力学习，所以谢谢你。我会把它回馈给你们俩。我想我们都来自挑战我们成为更好的人的背景。是的，阿门。是的。这完美地引出了我们的嘉宾。
I guess it does.
I was going to say, I mean, the warning signs were there.
I mean, your dad had five kids and he bought a two-seater.
So it's not, it's like this guy, he built an escape pod.
He was sending you guys signs.
It's so true.
A little MG convertible.
Yes.
我想是的。我本来想说，我是说，警告信号就在那里。我是说，你爸爸有五个孩子，他买了一辆双座车。所以这不像，就像这家伙，他造了一个逃生舱。他在给你们发信号。太真实了。一辆小MG敞篷车。是的。
I mean, it just wrote for him in a bag, like an overnight bag.
By the way, he had that too.
It's so true.
Anyway, I'll tell you something about it.
our guest.
She is really no stranger to awards.
SAG Awards, any kind of, you know,
it's insane.
我是说，他只是写了一张纸条放在包里，就像一个过夜包。顺便说一下，他也有那个。太真实了。总之，我会告诉你一些关于它的事。我们的嘉宾。她对奖项并不陌生。演员工会奖，任何种类的，你知道，这太疯狂了。
I mean, nominated for like 122 various awards
around the world, 19 wins.
And, you know, we're talking about,
what are we talking about?
We're talking about SAG's Critics' Choice.
Recently, an Academy Award,
I can't say what yet,
because you're going to know exactly who it is,
我是说，被提名了大约122个世界各地的各种奖项，19次获奖。而且，你知道，我们在谈论什么？我们在谈论演员工会奖、评论家选择奖。最近，一个奥斯卡奖，我还不能说是什么，因为你会确切地知道是谁，
and I want you to guess,
Emmys, everything she has,
and her, for pieces of work that we all really, really adore,
and she, stuff that we've all seen a million times,
and we're like, oh, yeah, the greatest.
Stuff like breaking out in, I am Sam, Daddy Daycare,
okay, all the way to the new predator bad,
and then this year's sentimental value
我想让你猜，艾美奖，她拥有的一切，以及她，为了我们所有人都非常、非常喜爱的作品，她，我们都看过一百万遍的东西，我们就像，哦，是的，最伟大的。像《我是山姆》、《奶爸日托》这样的作品，好的，一直到新的《铁血战士》，然后是今年的《感性价值》，
for which she is nominated for an Academy Award
for Best Supporting Actress.
You guys, it's another than L. Fanning.
Oh, my God, you had to be spinning.
I didn't know where you were going with this.
I know, I took you on a weird route
just to go into credits.
Did I take it off at the right time?
她凭借该片获得了奥斯卡最佳女配角提名。伙计们，除了艾丽·范宁还能有谁。天哪，你一定是在胡说八道。我不知道你要去哪里。我知道，我带你走了一条奇怪的路线，只是为了进入演职员表。我是在正确的时间把它关掉的吗？
You did.
Yes, that was great.
We usually have a guest in there.
We didn't even get to a guess.
I know.
But I just stopped.
First, you go, I am Sam.
I'm like, oh, God, they're going to think it's Dakota.
你做到了。是的，那太棒了。我们通常会在那里有一位嘉宾。我们甚至没能猜到。我知道。但我只是停下来。首先，你说，《我是山姆》。我就想，哦，天哪，他们会以为是达科塔。
No, I just wanted to throw them off the scent, Elle.
I wanted him to be thrown.
Wait, Elle, I just watched Badlands.
It was so good.
Oh, you did?
Oh, thank you.
I bugged Jason forever, and Jason's scheduling my schedule and never got together.
I was like, fuck it, I'm just going to watch it with that.
不，我只是想让他们偏离方向，艾丽。我想让他被误导。等等，艾丽，我刚看了《荒原》。太棒了。哦，你看过了？哦，谢谢。我一直缠着杰森，杰森在安排我的日程，从来没凑到一起。我就想，去他的，我只是要和那个一起看。
I hear that's incredible.
Thank you so much.
I am a real listener to this.
And my sister and I and our friend Chloe, we absolutely love your show and your documentary.
Oh, that's nice.
So this is a big deal.
I'm like sitting here, like my heart is pounding.
Well, we're so happy for you to be here.
我听说那太不可思议了。非常感谢。我是这个节目的忠实听众。我和我姐姐还有我们的朋友克洛伊，我们绝对喜欢你们的节目和纪录片。哦，那太好了。所以这是一件大事。我坐在这里，就像我的心在狂跳。好吧，我们很高兴你能来。
I do know Will, we've been seeing each other around.
Yes, yes, we.
Oh, congrats.
How long you guys been dating?
From the puck convention.
We can puck the website or puck a hockey thing or puck the website thing?
No.
Puck is a real, that's a for Tracy.
我确实认识威尔，我们一直在附近见到对方。是的，是的，我们。哦，恭喜。你们约会多久了？从冰球大会开始。我们可以冰球网站还是冰球曲棍球东西还是冰球网站东西？不。冰球是一个真实的，那是给特雷西的。
I wanted to get that in.
Yes.
Yeah.
Tell Trey, because I don't know what it is either.
No, that's a real listener.
Puck is, what is it, Will?
It's that guy, Matt, Matt, what's his name?
Matt Bologna?
我想把它加进去。是的。是的。告诉特雷，因为我也不知道那是什么。不，那是一个真正的听众。冰球是，那是什么，威尔？是那个家伙，马特，马特，他叫什么名字？马特·博洛尼？
Belloni?
Boy, I would get crushed for that.
He's a great, who's also, John Heilman and, right?
Yeah, there's a lot of great.
Am I right about that?
Is that the same crew?
Wait, I still don't know what, but, I mean, it's a website.
It's like an entertainment email thing.
贝洛尼？天哪，我会因为那个被压垮的。他是个伟大的，谁也是，约翰·海尔曼和，对吧？是的，有很多伟大的。我说的对吗？是同一组人吗？等等，我还是不知道什么，但是，我是说，这是一个网站。这就像一个娱乐电子邮件的东西。
too, right? People get, like, in the industry
you have to sign up for it and
it's like you get little
inside scoops and things? Yes.
Yeah, there's a bunch of stuff in there.
It's very, very hard. You must subscribe
to it, Jason. Oh, you know it, girl.
But wait a minute. For me, for me and my sister,
也是，对吧？人们得到，就像在行业里你必须注册它，然后就像你得到一些内部消息和东西？是的。是的，里面有很多东西。非常，非常难。你必须订阅它，杰森。哦，你知道的，女孩。但是等一下。对我，对我姐姐来说，
I still don't understand. So Puck
is a thing, like a website. It's like a newsletter.
It's like a newsletter. So you sign up, they send
an email that you sign up for thing. Yeah, it's like a website.
And how are you and how? And then you have access.
Like, how does that? Well, they did a, what was it
like a panel?
P&A, Panels.
我还是不明白。所以冰球是一个东西，就像一个网站。这就像一份通讯。这就像一份通讯。所以你注册，他们发送你注册的电子邮件。是的，这就像一个网站。你和怎么？然后你就有权限了。就像，那是怎么？好吧，他们做了一个，那是什么，像一个小组讨论？问答，小组讨论。
Q&A panel together.
Yeah, okay, got it, got it.
Yeah.
And he was there for his thing on,
and I was there for sentimental value.
Jesse Plymonds was with us, and Tessa Thompson.
Yeah.
Right, right.
一起问答小组。是的，好的，明白了，明白了。是的。他因为他的事情在那里，我因为《感性价值》在那里。杰西·普莱蒙和我们在一起，还有泰莎·汤普森。是的，对，对。
I've only heard amazing things about sentimental.
I can't wait to see it.
Can I tell you, sentimental value is so good.
I love that so much.
I don't know if I told, maybe I talked to you about it,
but I think I talked to you about it,
and your wonderful director,
Joaquin and Wachim Trier,
我只听过关于《感性价值》的惊人评价。我迫不及待想看它了。我可以告诉你吗，《感性价值》太好了。我非常喜欢它。我不知道我是否告诉过，也许我和你谈过它，但我认为我和你谈过它，还有你出色的导演，乔阿金和沃金·特里尔，
and also with Stellan and Renata,
how amazing that film is.
It's such a beautiful film.
It's such a, I mean, just the level of filmmaking in every department
from the direction to the acting to the production to all of it is so complete.
I mean, that is truly the height of great filmmaking, I think.
Thank you.
Yeah, it was an unreal experience with Yocham, and it was just really something.
还有斯特兰和雷娜塔，那部电影有多棒。那是一部如此美丽的电影。那是一个，我是说，从导演到表演到制作到所有的一切，每个部门的电影制作水平都如此完整。我是说，那确实是伟大电影制作的高度，我想。谢谢。是的，和约阿希姆在一起是一次不真实的经历，那真的很有意义。
Yonim, I said his name.
How do you pronounce his last name, too?
Is it trier or?
Trier.
Yeah.
How embarrassing.
I'm sure there's going to be a headline how we've just besmirched the guys.
约尼姆，我说了他的名字。他的姓怎么发音，也是？是特里尔还是？特里尔。特里尔。是的。多尴尬啊。我相信会有头条新闻说我们刚刚玷污了那些家伙。
A lot of people say Joaquin or Yokin or something.
Yeah.
If you were, if you had a Norwegian accent, they would say it different.
It would be like, Yor Kim.
York Kim.
Yeah.
Yor Kim.
Now I say Yon Kim.
很多人说乔阿金或约金之类的。是的。如果你有挪威口音，他们会说得不同。它会像，约金。约金。是的。约金。现在我说约尼姆。
Yon Kim.
Wait, Al, where are you right now?
Are you in New York?
I am in L.A.
Yes.
But I have been, my boyfriend lives in New York.
And so he just sent me actually a photo.
约尼姆。等等，艾丽，你现在在哪里？你在纽约吗？我在洛杉矶。我在洛杉矶。是的。但我一直，我男朋友住在纽约。所以他实际上刚给我发了一张照片。
Yeah, it's crazy in New York right now, isn't it?
He said these photos.
It's so nuts.
There was a tree that fell down in front of his house,
this giant tree, but it looks so cozy.
I mean, I'm in L.A., and it's, like, glorious and sunny outside,
so it's so crazy how opposite it is.
Yeah, you and J.
是的，纽约现在很疯狂，不是吗？他说这些照片。太疯狂了。他家门前倒了一棵树，这棵巨大的树，但看起来很舒适。我是说，我在洛杉矶，外面阳光明媚，太辉煌了，所以相反的情况太疯狂了。是的，你和J。
I know. I had, yeah, yeah, I just, I ventured out for two minutes.
My local coffee shop's closed.
Nobody went in because there's not, by the way, I just,
there's nothing open.
Nothing's open.
My gym was open, thank God, Obvi.
Wait, pause for compliment.
Nothing?
我知道。我有，是的，是的，我只是，我冒险出去了两分钟。我当地的咖啡店关门了。没人进去，因为没有，顺便说一下，我只是，没有开门的东西。什么都没开。我的健身房开了，谢天谢地，显然。等等，暂停一下赞美。什么都没有？
Okay, moving on.
Wait, so, Elle, you're in L.A.
You spent a lot of your life in L.A.
You were born, we're going to go early days.
You were born in it just outside Atlanta, I'm guessing, right?
Yes, yes.
I was born actually during a tornado warning.
Whoa.
好吧，继续。等等，所以，艾丽，你在洛杉矶。你一生中大部分时间都在洛杉矶。你出生，我们要回到早期。你出生在亚特兰大郊外，我猜，对吧？是的，是的。我实际上是在龙卷风警报期间出生的。哇。
Yeah.
I've been through a tornado warning in Atlanta.
It's not fun.
Well, I guess, yeah, I wasn't really, definitely don't remember it.
I was going through something else at the time.
Wait, so your mom was giving me birth to you while there was a tornado.
So, like, happening?
I don't think it was happening, but it was very close.
是的。我经历过亚特兰大的龙卷风警报。那不好玩。好吧，我想，是的，我真的，绝对不记得了。我当时正在经历别的事情。等等，所以你妈妈在龙卷风期间生下你？所以，就像，正在发生？我不认为它正在发生，但它非常接近。
And there was a warning.
So, like, the hospital, like, the hallways, like, there was kind of the shutdown.
Yeah, what do you do?
You don't think about that.
That meant that my sister was in the room while my mom gave birth.
And she was asleep on a cot next to the bed.
And my mom didn't find out with either of us, like, if we were a boy or a girl.
And so my mom gave birth, and then my sister woke up and, like, famously.
而且有一个警报。所以，就像，医院，就像，走廊，就像，有一种关闭。是的，你做什么？你不会想到那个。这意味着我姐姐在房间里，当时我妈妈生下了我。她睡在床边的一张行军床上。我妈妈生我们两个的时候都没有发现，我们是男孩还是女孩。所以我妈妈生了孩子，然后我姐姐醒了，就像，著名地。
And I think it's on camera.
we have like a video of it,
but she says,
she says,
what is it?
And it's like,
it's a baby sister.
And that,
而且我认为它在摄像机上。我们有像一段视频，但她说，她说，那是什么？就像，是一个妹妹。而那个，
yeah.
That's very sweet.
You're lucky your parents
didn't do that thing
of like decided to name you like NATO
or, you know,
F3 after the size of the hurricane.
I know.
是的。那太贴心了。你很幸运，你父母没有做那种决定给你起名叫北约，或者，你知道，F3，以飓风的大小命名。我知道。
Yeah, I was born in Georgia.
Like my family is very southern.
So even though,
yeah,
even though I grew up in L.A.,
like I moved here when I was three,
So I definitely don't remember Georgia that much
But the southern roots like run deep
是的，我出生在佐治亚州。就像我的家人非常南方。所以即使，是的，即使我在洛杉矶长大，就像我三岁时搬到这里，所以我绝对不记得佐治亚州那么多，但南方的根基很深。
And my grandmother lived with us growing up
And she still lives with my mom
And she would go with me on film sets
And my mom would go with my sister
Oh wow
Because when we were working at the same time
Yeah you were
And what I loved about reading
而且我祖母从小就和我们住在一起。她现在还和我妈妈住在一起。她会陪我拍电影。我妈妈会陪我姐姐。哦，哇。因为当我们同时工作时。是的，你当时。我喜欢阅读关于你的早期生活。
Reading up a little bit about your sort of early days
Is how your friend
And I mentioned I am Sam Lumpur
Because you did play a younger version
of your sister in the movie.
And someone like Wikipedia, of course,
we have a deep research department,
said that you,
读一点关于你早期生活的东西，就是你的朋友。我提到了《我是山姆》。因为你确实在电影里扮演了你姐姐的年轻版本。像维基百科这样的人，当然，我们有一个深入的研究部门，说你，
your first,
it sort of lists your first few credits,
and then it says her first role
where she wasn't playing a young version
of her sister.
Right, because I did it a couple times.
Yeah, they would throw me in.
Yeah, because they would, you know,
它列出了你的前几个作品，然后它说她第一个不是扮演她姐姐年轻版本的角色。对，因为我做了几次。是的，他们会把我扔进去。是的，因为他们会，你知道，
there would be flashback scenes,
and then they'd be trying to find a young girl
that looked like Dakota,
and then I would be on set, like, with my mom.
And they're like, actually, can we just use L real quick?
And so technically, and my mom's like, sure.
And they took me and I just got handed to Sean Penn
and we're swinging on the swing.
会有闪回场景，然后他们会试图找一个看起来像达科塔的小女孩，然后我会在片场，就像，和我妈妈在一起。他们就像，实际上，我们可以快速用一下艾丽吗？所以从技术上讲，我妈妈就像，当然。他们带走了我，我只是被交给了肖恩·潘，我们在秋千上荡秋千。
Wow.
Wow, that's the first moment.
Jason played a young Justine Bateman many times.
Many.
Right.
He's put in the extensions and off I went.
Throw out the hair.
What's the age difference between you two?
哇。哇，那是第一个时刻。杰森多次扮演年轻的贾斯汀·贝特曼。很多次。对。他戴上接发，我就走了。甩掉头发。你们两个年龄差多少？
She's four years older than me.
Okay.
And is just the two of you?
Just us, yep.
Just us.
Yeah.
And when's so...
她比我大四岁。好的。只有你们两个吗？只有我们，是的。只有我们。是的。那么什么时候……是的。
Well, how old were you when you guys started?
I'm getting to sort of this question about like missing childhood and all that stuff.
You're going down the dark way.
People love asking that to us child.
There's a great kind of, there's a great...
I know you worked a lot when you were a kid, but there's also...
There was a lot of normalcy there, and I was going to get to get to it.
but you go for it, Elle.
好吧，你们开始的时候多大？我正在谈论关于错过童年之类的事情。你要走黑暗路线了。人们喜欢问我们这些孩子。有一种伟大的，有一种伟大的……我知道你小时候工作很多，但也有……那里有很多正常的东西，我本来要谈到的。但你继续，艾丽。
Yeah, yeah.
I mean, that's definitely something, you know, that's asked.
I mean, I, the origin story, it's so funny because my sister's like,
you're not telling it exactly right.
And I'm like, well, I was a baby.
I'm like, you know, it's been told to me.
So, because a lot to do with my start is really her start into everything.
And so she was in, you know, Georgia.
是的，是的。我是说，那绝对是，你知道，被问到的。我是说，我，起源故事，太搞笑了，因为我姐姐说，你讲得不完全对。我说，好吧，我当时是个婴儿。我是说，你知道，这是别人告诉我的。所以，因为很多关于我的开始实际上是她进入一切的开始。所以她在，你知道，佐治亚州。
My mom and my dad, they were.
both athletes. My dad was a professional
baseball player. My mom was
played tennis in college. Her dad was a quarterback in the NFL
for the Eagles. What?
Yes. That's crazy.
Sports is in our blood and we were
really, yeah, we were really
我妈妈和我爸爸，他们是。都是运动员。我爸爸是职业棒球运动员。我妈妈在大学打网球。她爸爸是NFL老鹰队的四分卫。什么？是的。那太疯狂了。运动在我们的血液里，我们确实，是的，我们确实
supposed to, I think mom probably
thought that we would be tennis players
or something.
Oh really? Or, I mean, you know, something,
sporty. And it's funny, I mean, this
has to do with it. But like our mom is, she tans really easily, has really dark eyes, super dark
long hair. And so this, it all tracks because, um, our dad is part, he's German. His mom was
German. And so we kind of came out with this like fair, fair skin and this like white hair and
应该，我想妈妈可能认为我们会成为网球运动员之类的。哦，真的吗？或者，我是说，你知道，某种，运动型的。而且很有趣，我是说，这和它有关。但就像我们妈妈，她很容易晒黑，有非常深色的眼睛，超级深色的长发。所以这个，这一切都说得通，因为，嗯，我们爸爸是部分，他是德国人。他妈妈是德国人。所以我们出来时有这种白皙的皮肤和这种白色的头发和
blue eyes. And so when my sister, you know, she went out on the tennis court from, you know,
my mom got her out there young. She's like, you know, four, five, you know.
And she would just get so hot.
And, like, we don't tan.
Like, the sunburn was just insane.
And so she's like, oh, my God, like, my precious little, you know, fair-skinned, like, baby.
Like, she's just not cut out for this sport, like, you know, and then she put her in soccer.
And it's like, yeah, like, we need to get her indoors.
蓝眼睛。所以当我姐姐，你知道，她从，你知道，我妈妈很小就把她带到网球场上。她就像，你知道，四、五岁，你知道。她会变得很热。而且，就像，我们不会晒黑。就像，晒伤太疯狂了。所以她就像，哦，天哪，就像，我珍贵的，你知道，白皙皮肤的，就像，婴儿。就像，她根本不适合这项运动，就像，你知道，然后她让她去踢足球。就像，是的，就像，我们需要让她在室内。
Let's get her on a dark stage.
But I appreciate, you know, I think there's the athleticism and the discipline is actually really,
translated into acting.
Like, as I've gotten older, I really see the correlation to it.
Like I approach my work kind of in this athletic way.
Like a team sport?
Yeah, team sport, but also just, I think the adrenaline, like, hiking yourself up,
like making sure you're nourished, like, further.
让我们让她在黑暗的舞台上。但我很感激，你知道，我认为运动能力和纪律实际上确实转化为了表演。就像，随着年龄的增长，我真的看到了它们之间的相关性。就像我以这种运动方式对待我的工作。就像团队运动？是的，团队运动，但也只是，我认为肾上腺素，就像，让自己兴奋起来，就像，确保你营养充足，就像，进一步。
Like, there's just something to it that I think there is a correlation there.
And so then, I know I'm trying the origin story because it's kind of crazy.
But my mom wanted, you know, wanted Dakota to, because I wasn't bored.
yet, but to find her passion, like, okay, what are we going to put you?
And so then she was like, all right, you know, she did violin, she played the piano.
And my sister was like a savant.
Like, she is just, was always incredibly smart for her age.
And she has a photographic memory.
就像，这里面有一些东西，我认为那里有一种相关性。所以然后，我知道我正在尝试起源故事，因为它有点疯狂。但我妈妈想要，你知道，想要达科塔，因为我还没出生。但要找到她的热情，就像，好的，我们要把你放在哪里？所以然后她就像，好吧，你知道，她学了小提琴，她弹钢琴。我姐姐就像个天才。就像，她只是，一直对她的年龄来说非常聪明。而且她有照相记忆。
Her memory is insane, which doesn't help in arguments because she's completely always right.
Right.
And what that's like.
Yeah.
It's a burden.
And so then there was.
this, you know, then my mom kind of would observe my sister playing around the house constantly
她的记忆力太疯狂了，这在争论中没用，因为她完全总是对的。对。那是什么感觉。是的。这是一种负担。这是一种负担。所以然后有。这个，你知道，然后我妈妈会观察我姐姐在家里不断地玩耍
of just all she wanted to do was like play with her baby dolls. I mean, a lot of kids do,
but it was just very extreme in an elaborate in all of that. And then when I came along,
she got like this real life baby to play with, she could make it even more real. You know,
we would watch the TLC shows like my baby story. As a kid, we loved that. And all. And all,
Oh, we would play.
And then she would give birth to me.
So I would, like, come out of this bean bag, like, underneath her.
And, like, and we wouldn't perform this for people.
她只想玩她的洋娃娃。我是说，很多孩子都这样，但这在所有这些方面都非常极端和复杂。然后当我出生时，她得到了像这个现实生活中的婴儿来玩，她可以让它更真实。你知道，我们会看TLC节目，比如我的婴儿故事。小时候，我们喜欢那个。而且所有。而且所有，哦，我们会玩。然后她会生下我。所以我就会，就像，从这个豆袋里出来，就像，在她下面。而且，就像，我们不会为别人表演这个。
But we would do it for ourselves.
Right.
Like, push, push.
And it'd just be like a beanbag.
Oh, yes, yes.
And it's like, oh, God, we're losing her.
We're losing her.
You know, she's, like, pounding on me.
但我们会为自己做。对。就像，推，推。然后就像一个豆袋。哦，是的，是的。就像，哦，天哪，我们要失去她了。我们要失去她了。你知道，她就像，在捶打我。
And I'm playing along or just these real scenarios.
And so my mom, I mean, we're kind of jumping around,
but this was kind of, yeah, I guess Dakota was like five,
so I was around.
But she put her in this play camp in Georgia.
And the people at the play camp, they were putting on this,
I think it was called Bluefish, like this play.
And she got a big part in that play and just lit up, like found.
而我配合着，或者只是这些真实的场景。所以我想，我是说，我们有点跳跃，但这有点，是的，我猜达科塔当时大约五岁，所以我当时在附近。但她把她放在佐治亚州的这个戏剧营里。戏剧营的人，他们正在上演这个，我想它叫蓝鱼，就像这个戏剧。她在那个戏剧里得到了一个大角色，就像亮了起来，就像找到了。
They could just see something in her from the other kids that was different.
And they talked to my mom and were like, you know,
maybe she could do some commercials or get an agent here.
you know, maybe get a TV show or just, it wasn't, but it wasn't like, go to the movies.
It was just like, try this out type of thing.
Yeah, yeah.
And, I mean, mom had a genuine conversation, like, with Dakota at that age, like, is this
something you'd want to do?
他们能从其他孩子身上看出她有什么不同。他们和我妈妈谈过，就像，你知道，也许她可以拍一些广告或在这里找个经纪人。你知道，也许找个电视节目或者只是，它不是，但它不像，去拍电影。它只是像，尝试一下那种事情。是的，是的。而且，我是说，妈妈和那个年龄的达科塔进行了一次真诚的谈话，就像，这是你想做的事情吗？
And she's like, at any point, if this is, like, not fun for you, like, we're going to go home.
We won't do it.
Yeah.
And so then it eventually, she got an Asian in Georgia.
And then my mom and my sister, they went themselves to.
to L.A. because my aunt, who was a sideline reporter for the NFL at the time.
Wow. Good Lord.
她说，在任何时候，如果这，就像，对你来说不好玩，就像，我们要回家。我们不会做。是的。是的。所以然后它最终，她在佐治亚州得到了一个经纪人。然后我妈妈和我姐姐，她们自己去了。去洛杉矶，因为我阿姨，当时是NFL的场边记者。哇。天哪。
Yeah. She was living in L.A. and so my mom and my sister slept on her couch and, you know,
did pilot season. And I think she got Allie McBeal. She played the young Allie McBeal.
Oh. Wow. Yeah. And got commercials, you know. And then. So where does L come in?
No, no, I love it.
Well, this time I'm just like, I'm so young, but I'm watching. It's just,
becoming a part of my life from that age of seeing my sister, oh, going on these auditions,
and then, oh, then she gets to dress up and gets to go to other places. And it's like, I want to do
that. It really was a copycat. Like, I call myself like a Nepo sister in a way because I completely
是的。她住在洛杉矶，所以我妈妈和我姐姐睡在她的沙发上，你知道，做了试播季。我想她得到了《艾莉的异想世界》。她扮演了年轻的艾莉。哦。哇。是的。而且得到了广告，你知道。然后。所以艾丽在哪里出现？不，不，我喜欢它。好吧，这次我只是像，我太年轻了，但我正在看。它只是，从那个年龄开始成为我生活的一部分，看到我姐姐，哦，去参加这些试镜，然后，哦，然后她可以打扮，可以去其他地方。就像，我想做那个。它确实是一个模仿者。就像，我称自己为像一个星二代姐妹，因为我完全
just copied her because I would visit her on sets all the time, which also, Cat in the Hat, Sean.
You were in Cat in the Hat? With Dakota, yeah. Did you come by? Did I meet you? Probably met you
as a child. I was on set all the time. Oh, my gosh.
How many times a day do you say, how many times a day do you say, did I meet you?
Just guess, ballpark.
We'll be right back.
And now, back to the show.
So, but what about school for the both of you guys?
只是复制了她，因为我会一直去片场看她，这也，戴帽子的猫，肖恩。你演了《戴帽子的猫》？和达科塔一起，是的。你来过吗？我见过你吗？可能在你小时候见过你。我一直都在片场。哦，天哪。你一天说多少次，你一天说多少次，我见过你吗？只是猜，大概数字。我们马上回来。现在，回到节目。所以，但你们两个的学校怎么样？
Like, did you have a very normal childhood?
Like, looking back now.
Kind of, right?
Yes, we really did.
Sorry, that one was for L, Will.
No, no.
Will, how did you have a normal childhood?
I'm sorry.
就像，你们有一个非常正常的童年吗？就像，现在回想起来。有点，对吧？是的，我们确实。抱歉，那个是给艾丽的，威尔。不，不。威尔，你怎么有一个正常的童年？抱歉。
Yeah.
Willie?
Oh my gosh.
No, but you did?
So you went to public schools and stuff like that?
Yeah, my sister went to, she was homeschooled.
Okay.
是的。威利？是的。哦，天哪。不，但你确实？所以你们上了公立学校之类的？是的，我姐姐上了，她在家上学。好的。
For a long time until ninth grade in high school.
And so then that meant like the age-wise, I was homeschooled by my grandmother until fourth grade.
And so at that, at those two ages, we just kind of felt like we wanted, you know, I think our mom wanted.
us to have that experience.
You know, it's very much an experience that our mom had.
Like, she just never had a, she is shy, she's not, like, no one is in the business.
Like, this is just not, this is not how she saw her life going.
And then it was like, Dakota just kind of kept getting jobs.
很长一段时间，直到高中九年级。所以这意味着，年龄方面，我直到四年级都是由我祖母在家教育的。所以在那，在那两个年龄，我们只是觉得我们想要，你知道，我想我妈妈想要。我们有那种经历。你知道，这非常像我妈妈有的经历。就像，她从来没有一个，她很害羞，她不是，就像，没有人从事这个行业。就像，这只是不是，这不是她看待自己生活的方式。然后就像，达科塔只是不断地得到工作。
And then we're like, she always thought, oh, we're going to move back to Georgia.
And then they never did.
Because she kept getting things and, like, moved to L.A.
Right.
And so my mom was really, you know, figuring out,
she was going along as well.
It's interesting because my sister, her birthday is today.
Oh, happy birthday, Dakota.
然后我们就像，她总是想，哦，我们要搬回佐治亚州。然后他们从来没有。因为她不断地得到东西，就像，搬到了洛杉矶。对。所以我想我妈妈真的，你知道，在弄清楚，她也跟着一起。这很有趣，因为我姐姐，她的生日是今天。哦，生日快乐，达科塔。
Yeah, but she's 32.
But it's interesting because we're like,
mom was 32 when she was on set with I Am Sam, like navigating this, you know,
when Sean Pins like method, you know, talking to Dakota and just they're having to
navigate that together.
It's just so interesting.
They're kind of sweet to think about our young mom dealing with that.
Yeah, that's really cool.
是的，但她32岁了。但这很有趣，因为我们就像，妈妈在《我是山姆》片场时32岁，就像在导航这个，你知道，当肖恩·潘像方法派，你知道，和达科塔说话，他们不得不一起导航那个。这太有趣了。想到我们年轻的妈妈处理那个，真是太贴心了。是的，那真的很酷。
Yeah.
But, yes, schools, it's, yes, we were homeschooled.
And then it was like, I think, you know, I was like, I don't really have any friends my own age.
And I want to have that experience.
And so, mom's like, yeah, certainly, you know, wanted proms and the parties and the whole thing.
And so we went to the same school and it was a private school here in L.A.
Yeah.
That's great.
是的。但是，是的，学校，它是，是的，我们在家上学。然后就像，我想，你知道，我就像，我真的没有和我同龄的朋友。我想有那种经历。所以，妈妈就像，是的，当然，你知道，想要舞会和派对以及整个事情。所以我们上了同一所学校，那是洛杉矶的一所私立学校。是的。那太棒了。
Yeah.
And then did, again, I'm just, I find myself, I'm just projecting here, just thinking about all of my, you know.
Oh, take us away on this jury.
Yeah.
So for me, but did you guys think about college?
I didn't know there were tickets left on the journey.
You guys, do you guys just kind of blew right by college, kind of like I did thinking like, oh, I'm good.
I've got my career started.
是的。然后做了，再次，我只是，我发现自己，我只是在这里投射，只是在想我所有的，你知道。哦，带我们离开这个陪审团。是的。所以对我来说，但你们想过大学吗？我不知道旅程中还有票。你们，你们只是有点吹过了大学，有点像我一样想，哦，我很好。我已经开始了我的职业生涯。
I don't need it.
And it's stressful, right?
I certainly did.
I was not sure.
I was so done with school.
I knew from pretty quick, I'm not going to college.
Dakota did.
Dakota went to NYU.
我不需要它。而且这很有压力，对吧？我当然做了。我不确定。我受够了学校。我很快就知道，我不上大学。达科塔上了。达科塔去了纽约大学。
Okay, good.
She's much more student.
than I and has much more like the attention span and she's got a backup career in her back
pocket I know we say she should be she we always tell her like she should be should have been a
lawyer I mean not should have but right she still can be yeah she still can be yeah that's why
wait I want to just say one sidebar about homeschool because I I I don't know anything about it
it just imagine oh well definitely go off on it then yeah let's have your hot take I I
I always imagine when somebody says they're homeschooled,
好的，很好。她比我更学生。而且有更多的，就像注意力跨度，她在后兜里有一个备用职业。我知道我们说她应该，她，我们总是告诉她，就像她应该，本应该成为一名律师。我是说，不是应该，但对，她仍然可以。是的，她仍然可以。是的，这就是为什么，等等，我想关于在家教育说一个侧边栏，因为我，我，我对此一无所知，只是想象，哦，好吧，一定要去谈谈它。是的，让我们听听你的热门观点。我，我总是想象当有人说他们在家上学时，
like, how,
like, who's checking to see if you're done your home?
Like, how does it, you know, like, you just wake up,
you're like, man, you can't say I don't feel like going to class
because your class is in your house.
You know, like, I would cut class all the time.
Sure you would.
You'd be late a lot.
就像，怎么，就像，谁在检查看你是否完成了你的家庭作业？就像，它是怎么，你知道，就像，你只是醒来，你就像，伙计，你不能说我不想去上课，因为你的课在你的房子里。你知道，就像，我会一直逃课。你当然会。你会经常迟到。
Yeah, I'd be late or whatever.
I'd be late almost every day to school.
But yeah, but there's no, like, anyway, we don't have to go into it.
It was, no, it was like a curriculum that was,
a full curriculum and they would send you all of the books.
And then your quote teacher is your grandmother.
Yes. And then I also had a studio teacher that was the same studio teacher with me.
Even when I was in my regular school and would leave and go back and forth.
是的，我会迟到或者别的。我几乎每天上学都会迟到。但是，是的，但没有，就像，总之，我们不必深入探讨它。它是，不，它就像一个课程，是一个完整的课程，他们会寄给你所有的书。然后你的所谓老师是你祖母。是的。然后我还有一个工作室老师，他和我同一个工作室老师。即使我在我的正规学校，也会来回走动。
And we had to keep up with the assignments.
Got it was also, I mean, it was interesting because I felt like I learned a lot more.
Like the certain curriculum, they taught us cursive first.
instead of, and which is kind of reversed.
When I went into school, like, a lot of my,
they didn't know cursive us and they thought it was kind of weird.
Like, why are you doing cursive?
I'm like, oh, that's what I was taught first before.
我们必须跟上作业。明白了，它也是，我是说，这很有趣，因为我觉得我学到了更多。就像某些课程，他们先教我们草书。而不是，这有点反过来。当我进入学校时，就像，我的很多，他们不知道草书，他们觉得这有点奇怪。就像，你为什么要写草书？我就像，哦，那是我在之前先被教的东西。
And so it was kind of like an advanced.
Right.
I know what you mean about the college thing, though,
because it's like I completely advocate for everybody going to college
just for the experience of it, right?
Yeah.
But I understand when people, like, want to pursue acting or something.
because if you have a degree in act and being an act like theater or an actor,
所以它有点像高级。对。我知道你关于大学的事情是什么意思，因为就像我完全主张每个人都去上大学，只是为了那种经历，对吧？是的。但我理解当人们，就像，想要追求表演或什么的时候。因为如果你有表演学位，就像戏剧或演员，
it doesn't help you get a job like either you're right for a part or you're not right for a part.
But I mean, I still.
As a doctor, you need to have that diploma and the credentials and all that stuff before you can.
Right. Yeah.
I still advocate for people going to study because I...
We heard the first cover.
Yeah, we're really covered on that point in case you're worried about taking fire.
By the way, and by the way, just a little plug.
它不能帮助你找到工作，就像要么你适合一个角色，要么你不适合一个角色。但我，我是说，我仍然。作为一名医生，你需要有那个文凭和证书以及所有那些东西，在你能够之前。对。是的。我仍然主张人们去学习，因为我……我们听到了第一个封面。是的，我们真的涵盖了那一点，以防你担心受到攻击。顺便说一下，顺便说一下，一个小小的插件。
I have a scholarship set up at Illinois State University for theater kids.
I do, I...
Well, there's a long way to get to that.
I'll tell you what.
That's a plug.
It's important.
No, I had...
My thing was, I dropped out after one semester
我在伊利诺伊州立大学为戏剧孩子设立了奖学金。我确实，我……好吧，那是一个很长的路要走。我告诉你什么。那是一个插件。这很重要。不，我有……我的事情是，我一个学期后退学了
because I was like, I want to get out into the world
and I want to get doing the thing I want to do.
That was it for me.
Let's do this, you were saying.
Yeah.
Yeah, let's do it.
Let's get on to this.
That's how I felt.
因为我就像，我想进入世界，我想做我想做的事情。对我来说就是那样。让我们做这个，你刚才说。是的。是的，让我们做吧。让我们开始吧。我就是那种感觉。
I mean, yeah, it was, yeah.
So, Al, what was the first gig where you were actually front and center
and not a stand-in for your sister,
that you were up, you're at your front and center,
and you were like, wait a minute, this is really cool,
and I really get it.
Yes, there was, gosh, I'm trying to remember the very first.
I mean, I definitely, I mean, I did, you know,
我是说，是的，它是，是的。所以，艾丽，你第一次真正站在前台，而不是你姐姐的替身，你站在前台，你就像，等一下，这真的很酷，我真的明白了。是的，有，天哪，我正在努力回忆第一个。我是说，我绝对，我是说，我做了，你知道，
I had a lot of commercials.
I did the, you know, law and order stint.
You know, I burned down a house as like a crazy, you know,
demon child.
And, you know, I had the right of passage there.
What was your style of burning?
Was it like lighter fluid?
How did you burn down the house?
我有很多广告。我做了，你知道，法律与秩序的客串。你知道，我烧毁了一所房子，就像一个疯狂的，你知道，恶魔孩子。而且，你知道，我在那里有通过仪式。你烧毁房子的风格是什么？是像打火机油吗？你是怎么烧毁房子的？
Do you remember what your character did?
I don't remember.
Asking for it.
A bunch of old newspapers.
Yeah, I don't remember exactly.
Because there's a bunch of different ways to do it.
It might have just been, I don't know if they showed me doing it.
It was more like, you know, fire starter.
你记得你的角色做了什么吗？我不记得了。要求它。一堆旧报纸。是的，我不记得确切了。因为有几种不同的方法可以做到。它可能只是，我不知道他们是否展示了我做它。它更像，你知道，火种。
Like I was just like this girl in front of the burning building.
Didn't come out of your eyes or anything like that?
No, no.
But criminal minds, they really loved me.
They brought, I was kidnapped twice, the same character.
I was brought back.
To get kidnapped again.
Get kidnapped again?
就像我只是像这个女孩在燃烧的建筑物前。没有从你的眼睛里出来或者类似的东西？不，不。但犯罪心理，他们真的很喜欢我。他们带了，我被绑架了两次，同一个角色。我被带回来了。去再次被绑架。再次被绑架？
Yes.
The best kicking and screaming we've ever seen.
Not since Liam Neeson, yeah.
Yeah, so that was a big thing.
Sean, after being kidnapped,
how quickly would they let you go, do you think?
If they talk.
Oopsie.
是的。我们见过的最好的踢打和尖叫。自连姆·尼森以来，是的。是的，所以那是一件大事。肖恩，在被绑架后，你认为他们会多快让你走？如果他们说话。哎呀。
Like on the ride to the hideout?
Well, you know, as Oprah says,
never let them take you to the second location.
But, yeah, the first movie, Sean asked something.
You're about to stay the first job on your own.
Like when the fire started,
Like when that flame first started
Like, oh, wait, this is exciting
就像在去藏身处的路上？好吧，你知道，正如奥普拉所说，永远不要让他们把你带到第二个地点。但是，是的，第一部电影，肖恩问了一些事情。你正要说你自己的第一份工作。就像火开始的时候，就像那火焰第一次开始的时候，就像，哦，等等，这很令人兴奋
Was it like all of those little episodic things?
You're like, wait a minute, this is really, really thrilling.
Yeah, I remember there was a movie I did
called Phoebe in Wonderland.
And I was nine, it was with Felicity Huffman
and Patricia Clarkson and Bill Pullman.
They're all great.
Yeah, and I played Phoebe.
是像所有那些小插曲一样吗？你就像，等一下，这真的，真的很惊险。是的，我记得我拍了一部电影叫《菲比梦游仙境》。我当时九岁，和费莉西蒂·霍夫曼、帕特里夏·克拉克森和比尔·普尔曼一起。他们都很棒。是的，我扮演了菲比。
So, like, my name was in the title
and it was about a young girl who had Tourette's syndrome.
And I realized it was the first time
that I, you know, had to learn about something and portray something in like a sensitive way.
I mean, yes, I was young, but I realized, oh, there's another layer to acting, obviously, of like,
I have to transform into this person and kind of, it's a very specific experience that I don't know,
that I have to learn about.
And I talk to kids that had it.
所以，我的名字出现在了片名里，那部戏讲的是一个患有妥瑞氏症的小女孩。我意识到这是我第一次，你知道，必须去了解某样东西，并以一种敏感的方式去演绎它。我是说，是的，我当时很年轻，但我意识到，哦，演戏显然还有另一层含义，就是我必须转化成这个人，这是一种非常特殊的体验，我不知道，我必须去学习。我还和患有这种病的孩子们聊过。
And so that was very unique.
And just to be, for the first time, like, the,
person who was like number one on the call sheet like I was feeding yeah and and go deep like that
yeah that's really cool I remember watching what's eating Gilbert grape and I'd never even heard of
Leonardo DiCaprio never saw it so good and when Leonardo DiCaprio came on as that character I was like
oh my gosh how do they cast that kid like yeah he was stunning that kid and you're like oh he did
what that was a part like that blew my mind as I'm sure he was so good what what well else so that
that happened what was the first film when you were kind of on
所以那是非常独特的。而且第一次成为通告单上的第一位，就像我在喂养……是的，深入挖掘那种感觉，真的太酷了。我记得看《不一样的天空》时，我甚至都没听说过莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥，从来没见过，太棒了。当莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥以那个角色出现时，我心想，天哪，他们是怎么选到那个孩子的？他真是太惊人了，你会想，哦，他做了什么？那是一个让我大开眼界的角色，我相信他演得太好了。那么，当你开始……
on your own.
Like you really felt like you were an adult
and really had agency over you.
I mean, you always had agency over the rules
and stuff you wanted to do.
But that time when you were...
Or mostly you're just auditioning
and you're trying to get the best thing
当你独立的时候，你真的觉得自己是个成年人了，并且对自己有了掌控权。我是说，你一直对你想做的角色和事情有掌控权。但那段时间，当你……或者大部分时间你只是在试镜，试图争取最好的机会，
and it just so happens that, oh, you know, you got the part.
So you can't really pick when you're...
But what was the first thing that you, like, chose,
that you picked, that you felt like this is,
all right, I want to do it, I'm an adult,
this is the kind of stuff I want to do.
Do you remember, was there a certain thing that you...
Gosh, I know, it's so funny because
结果刚好，哦，你知道，你得到了那个角色。所以你不能真的去挑选……但你第一次真正选择的、你觉得“好吧，我想做这个，我是个成年人了，这就是我想做的那种事”的作品是什么？你还记得吗，有没有什么特定的事情……天哪，我知道，这太有趣了，因为
there's also so many different chapters
that I can pinpoint of like
remembering like I felt like
somewhere was a film that I did that I auditioned for that
that I was 11 but that was the first time that people
started somewhere and Super 8
it was Sophia's film yes with Steven Dorff
and we filmed the Chateau
我能指出很多不同的阶段，比如我记得我试镜过一部电影，当时我11岁，那是人们开始……在《超级8》里，那是索菲亚的电影，是的，和斯蒂芬·多尔夫一起，我们在城堡拍摄。
and Super 8 that was with JJ Abrams
they were kind of close I was 12 in that
but those were the first times I started getting recognized
not as Dakota fanning because constantly
I would just always get recognized
nice as Dakota. I'm sure, yeah. And so that was like a, there was like a kind of stepping stone there
and like another chapter. What is coming to mind with like a role that I chose that really felt
like I, I fought for it was the neon demon, this film I did with Nicholas Winding Refen,
还有《超级8》，那是和J·J·艾布拉姆斯合作的，那两部戏时间很近，我当时12岁，但那是人们开始认出我，而不是仅仅认出“达科塔·范宁”的第一次，因为我总是被认作达科塔。我确定，是的。所以那就像是一个垫脚石，是另一个篇章。我想到的一个我真正觉得是我自己争取来的角色是《霓虹恶魔》，那是我和尼古拉斯·温丁·雷弗恩合作的电影，
who directed Drive. Right. Oh, yeah. And Drive had just come out and it was this, I mean, it was
a crazy script.
Yeah, and that film was incredibly ambitious too.
Yeah, I remember the excitement around him right after Drive, too.
Yeah, that was awesome.
And the script was, you know, I was 17 when I filmed it.
And it was, I guess, quote unquote, I mean, I was playing a 17-year-old girl,
but it was kind of the horror, it was intense, like it was, like, again,
他导演了《亡命驾驶》。对。哦，是的。而且《亡命驾驶》刚上映，那是一个疯狂的剧本。是的，那部电影也非常有野心。是的，我记得《亡命驾驶》之后围绕他的那种兴奋感。是的，那太棒了。剧本是……你知道，我拍的时候17岁。我想，引用一句，我是说，我演的是一个17岁的女孩，但那有点像恐怖片，很强烈，就像……再次，
kind of polarizing with the themes.
kind of like the substance in a way, like pre the substance. It was about, you know, beauty in the modeling
industry and, um, and it was kind of extreme, but I, I was like, I want to do this. Like I saw
something in it and I, and obviously, I mean, Nick was from Drive. I mean, he was a big, you know,
director that people wanted to work with. And so it was a part that a lot of people wanted,
but it was something that I really like pushed for and, and wanted to go there. And I think,
people in the industry, I don't know, I think it went to Cannes and it, you know, got booze
and then got applause and it was like very polarizing. But I enjoyed that, that it was not,
主题有点两极分化。有点像《某种物质》那样，在《某种物质》之前。它是关于，你知道，模特行业的美，而且，嗯，它有点极端，但我当时想，我想做这个。我从中看到了某种东西，而且显然，尼克是拍《亡命驾驶》的。我是说，他是一位大家都想合作的大导演。所以那是一个很多人都想要的角色，但我真的争取了，而且想去尝试。我想，业内人士，我不知道，我想它去了戛纳，然后得到了嘘声，又得到了掌声，非常两极分化。但我很享受这一点，因为它不是，
you know, straight down the middle and it was my first time kind of doing something like that.
Yeah. What, where, do you see so, so, so the job obviously of being an actor is playing
different people. And can I, this is going to be a weird question.
Oh, boy. But like, did you find,
as a kid, when you're just learning who you are and becoming who you are,
did you find it confusing to be asking yourself to be all these different people at a time
when you're trying to figure out who you are?
I mean, I just, I thought that was confusing for me.
你知道，平铺直叙的，那是我第一次做那种事情。是的。那么，你觉得……演戏的工作显然就是扮演不同的人。我可以问一个奇怪的问题吗？哦，天哪。但是，你有没有发现，作为一个孩子，当你还在学习你是谁、正在成为谁的时候，要求你在试图弄清楚自己是谁的同时去扮演所有这些不同的人，这会让你感到困惑吗？我是说，我只是觉得这对我很困惑。
You know, like, we didn't become schizophrenics, but like you're really trying to be a
convincing version of something that you're not at a time when you're trying to figure out
who you are.
So how was that for you?
that is really good
it's something I haven't
completely thought about
Get it out now
你知道，就像，我们没有变成精神分裂症患者，但你确实是在试图成为一个你不是的人的令人信服的版本，而此时你正在试图弄清楚自己是谁。所以这对你来说怎么样？这真的很好，这是我还没有完全想过的事情。现在说出来吧。
This is the place to get it out
This is the moment right here
I think that
I think it can be helpful
Maybe right
It's just something that I hadn't thought about
I think yeah
I think there was
这就是说出来的地方，就是现在这一刻。我想，我想这可能会有帮助，也许吧。这只是我还没想过的事情。我想，是的，我想有……
For me
Acting in the experience
I just felt like it was so enriching
Like there's nothing
Like for me
It's added so much
To my life
And like expanded my life
对我来说，演戏的经历，我只是觉得它太丰富了。就像没有什么……对我来说，它给我的生活增添了太多东西，扩展了我的生活。
life of getting to also know how to handle yourself like around adults and and and and be in those
social situations and and and go to other countries and experience like it was just kind of it opened
my world in a way that it seemed I was like oh this is normal but it's obviously not the normal
and then playing characters I mean I'm a real big I live in my head a lot and I'm a big daydreamer
and kind of like my imagination
more than reality anyway.
So I felt like I found a place that I could expose all of those inner thoughts.
Yeah, an experiment.
那种学会如何与成年人相处，身处那些社交场合，去其他国家体验生活的感觉，它以一种似乎让我觉得“哦，这是正常的”方式打开了我的世界，但显然这并不正常。然后扮演角色，我是说，我是一个非常……我经常活在自己的脑海里，我是一个爱做白日梦的人，比起现实，我更喜欢我的想象力。所以我感觉我找到了一个可以释放所有这些内心想法的地方。是的，一个实验场。
And almost put on different types of clothes and different personalities.
And I did that not so much in my real life, but I got to act that out through the characters
I played when I was younger.
So it wasn't confusing.
It was more like cathartic, I guess, to have it.
outlet like that.
Can you point to any character that you feel that you adopted still to this day that's
become a kind of a good part of your personality?
几乎可以穿上不同类型的衣服，展现不同的个性。我并没有在现实生活中做太多，但我可以通过我年轻时扮演的角色来演绎出来。所以这并不令人困惑。我觉得这更像是一种宣泄，有这样一个出口。你能指出任何一个你觉得至今仍保留着，并成为你性格中一部分的角色吗？
Jason, another great follow-up.
I know.
Guys, I've done a lot of work.
A lot of work on this interview.
That's a really good question.
It wasn't someone that I played when I was younger, younger, but I was in the show The Great
where I played Catherine the Great.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
杰森，又一个很棒的后续问题。我知道。伙计们，我做了很多功课。在这个采访上做了很多功课。那真是个好问题。那不是我小时候演的角色，但我参演了《凯瑟琳大帝》，我在里面饰演凯瑟琳大帝。哦，是的，是的，是的。
Yes, we did it for three seasons.
Nicholas Holt.
Yes, he played Peter the third,
and we were married a couple,
and Tony McNamara, who wrote the favorite, wrote it.
So it was very, you know, we had an asterisk that said,
like, this is not historically accurate,
like, before the show happened in, like, a tongue-in-cheek way,
是的，我们拍了三季。尼古拉斯·霍尔特。是的，他饰演彼得三世，我们是一对夫妻，托尼·麦克纳马拉，写过《宠儿》的那位，写了这部剧。所以它非常，你知道，我们有一个星号，上面写着“这在历史上是不准确的”，就像在剧集开始前以一种半开玩笑的方式，
and it was raunchy and definitely not about history.
Yeah, it's really stylized.
It was awesome.
Yeah, it was kind of in that, in that favorite, like, tone, the rhythm.
It was very written, very, we had to be punctuation-perfect,
word perfect and, you know, it was a real, you know, you had to hit the joke.
Yeah, it was a real challenge.
But I felt like Tony was watching me kind of come to my own as a woman.
而且它很粗俗，绝对不是关于历史的。是的，它非常有风格。太棒了。是的，它有点像《宠儿》的那种基调、节奏。它写得非常精细，我们必须标点符号完美、用词完美，而且，你知道，你必须把笑点演出来。是的，这是一个真正的挑战。但我感觉托尼在看着我作为一个女人逐渐成熟。
Because I started the first season, I was 19, 20, and then we finished when I was 25.
Wow.
So 100% my personality was informing what Tony was writing throughout the seasons.
Catherine was, I was absorbing her.
And to this day, I feel like she's the most like me,
which could be better.
I mean, there's a lot of negative things to her as well.
But she was a very messy character and complicated.
因为我开始第一季时是19、20岁，然后我们结束时我25岁。哇。所以我的个性百分之百地融入了托尼在几季中创作的内容。凯瑟琳，我在吸收她。直到今天，我觉得她是最像我的角色，这可能是件好事。我是说，她也有很多负面特质。但她是一个非常混乱且复杂的角色。
And I think also people sometimes want to put you in a box of,
I mean, especially me, like, ooh, you laugh all the time and you know,
and you're naive.
And, you know, that is something, you know, I did maleficia.
I played Sleeping Beauty.
So I was a Disney princess.
And so to be able to do this show where I technically was playing an empress,
a queen that came into the ruling and had a coup on her husband
而且我认为人们有时想把你框住，我是说，尤其是对我，比如，噢，你总是笑，你知道，你很天真。而且，你知道，那是某件事，你知道，我演了《沉睡魔咒》。我演了睡美人。所以我是一个迪士尼公主。所以能够做这部剧，我技术上是在扮演一位女皇，一位掌权并对丈夫发动政变的皇后，
when she was super young, but she was super underestimated,
but had this really calculating side to her.
You got to show all the stuff that's under.
Yeah, she would use her naivete.
And I feel like, ooh, I kind of, I think I do that.
And so she was like me.
Good.
Yeah, yeah, because you're a good,
当她非常年轻的时候，但她被严重低估了，却有非常精明的一面。你得展示所有隐藏的东西。是的，她会利用她的天真。我觉得，噢，我有点，我想我确实那样做。所以她就像我。很好。是的，是的，因为你是一个好演员，而且天哪，当人们说“噢，你总是笑，总是很积极”，好像那是一件坏事。我和你有过一点那种经历，肖尼，你看……噢，我以为你要说，因为我感觉很多，因为虽然我在外表上超级毛茸茸，但我内心其实很赤裸和秃顶。
actor and also like God forbid
that when people are like oh you laugh and positive
all the time like that's a bad thing
I had a little bit of that experience
Shawnee with you watch
oh I thought you were to say because I feel a lot of that
because like well I'm super hairy on the outside
I'm pretty naked and bald on the inside of that
我感觉很多那种真正的“少年狼人”能量。不，但肖尼，我当时在想，这整件事，你看，你几周前做的那个单人秀。就像，在那场演出中，有那么多，你知道，深度和黑暗。而你做得如此毫不费力。我心想，是的，在所有的温暖和慷慨之下，那个为了让别人感到舒适而表现出来的你，其实是一个极其深刻、严肃的人。凶猛。是的，黑暗。是的。而且我唯一不买账的部分是你走路。
I feel a lot of that sort of like a real teen wolf energy
no but Shawnee I I was thinking that
it's a whole thing seeing Shawnee you know you do
that the one-man show a couple weeks ago.
Like, there's so much sort of, like, you know,
deepness and darkness and at times during that show.
And you just do it so effortlessly.
I'm like, yeah, there's the guy underneath all the warmth
你会走到河边，因为我知道你会打车或叫优步，你不可能走路。那让我出戏了。那让我出戏了。我不认为你不能拥有，即使在剧本里，我总是寻找这个。就像你不能拥有难以置信的快乐，
and the generosity that you socially, you know,
put forward to people to put them at ease.
There's like this incredibly deep, serious person.
Ferocious.
Yeah, dark.
Yeah.
And the only part I didn't buy is that you would walk.
that you would walk over to the river
而没有深刻的悲伤。就像它行不通。是的。而且就像我们四个现在在这里交谈一样。就像我们每个人都有很多很多别人见过和没见过的侧面。所以如果人们认为你没有那一面，你知道，这默认就是好莱坞的一件事，你知道，
because I know you'd take a cab
or you'd take a Uber
there's no way you'd walk.
That took me out.
I don't think that you can't have like,
even in like scripts or I always like look for this.
Like you can't have like incredible joy
就像，不，你永远不能那样做，因为……是的，你肯定会被定型。是的。我对此很了解。顺便说一句，我们在开场白里没提到，艾尔，你的新剧即将在A24为苹果首播，《玛戈有钱财烦恼》。
without like deep sorrow.
Like it doesn't work.
Yeah.
And it's also like any four of us right now talking.
It's like we have tons and tons of different sides of us
that people have seen and people haven't seen.
And so for people to think that you don't have that
You know, is just by default a Hollywood thing, you know,
那是“有钱财烦恼”。玛戈有钱财烦恼。玛戈有钱财烦恼。哦，等一下。哦，等一下。不，她是“有钱财烦恼”。等一下。我刚才停顿了一下。
that's like, no, you could never do that because...
Yeah, you get typecast for sure.
Yeah.
I know all about it.
By the way, so we didn't, I didn't mention in the opener, L, this, your new show that's
going to premiere A24 for Apple, Margot's Got Money.
Troubles.
我刚才停顿了一下。这是关于玛戈·罗比的纪录片吗？因为我们刚听过她。她没提到有任何现金问题。我不认为她有什么钱财烦恼。等等，艾尔，这是一本书吗？这是一本书。我想我读过那本书。
That's got money troubles.
Margo's got money troubles.
Oh, wait a minute.
No, she's got money troubles.
Wait a minute.
I was pausing.
不确定。是的，而且是不确定。是的，鲁比·索普。就是那本。就是我读的那本。一定是，是的，书名非常具体。是的。哦，那太酷了。
I was taking a pause.
Was this a documentary on Margot Robbie?
Because we just heard her on.
She didn't mention having any issues of cash.
I don't think she has any money troubles.
Wait, Al, was this a book?
It was a book.
I think I read that book.
是的，她是一个年轻的妈妈，她没有现金，所以她加入了OnlyFans。是的，我想是的。天哪。这太酷了。是的，而且它非常，它在很多方面都很酷……我是说，首先，它有一个很棒的演员阵容。是的。而且你和你姐姐也担任制片人，对吧？
Not sure.
Yes, and it was not sure.
Yeah, Ruby Thorpe.
That was the one.
That was the one I read.
It had to be, yeah, the title's very specific.
Yeah.
Oh, that's so cool.
你和你姐姐一起开了一家制作公司，是真的吗？叫卢埃林影业。哦，那很有趣。那很有趣。以我们已故的狗命名。啊。我们马上回来。回到节目。
Yeah, she's a young mom and she doesn't have the cash, and so she joins OnlyFans.
Yes, I think yes.
Oh, my God.
This is so cool.
Yes, and it's super, it's cool on a lot of...
I mean, first of all, it's got an amazing cast.
Yeah.
And you and your sister produce it as well, right?
我有一个笨问题。你们除了小时候的东西，作为成年人一起拍过电影吗？没有，下个月就要发生了。不会吧，不会吧。是什么？是的，我们从来没有一起读过台词，从来没有。我们在片场探过班，但我们没有，我们从来没有……从来没有一起出现在镜头前，除了，你知道，我演她小时候，但我们显然没有在一起。所以，是的，我们要拍《夜莺》，那是克里斯汀·汉娜的畅销书，我们在里面演姐妹。这是一个二战时期的姐妹故事。哇。哇，那太酷了。那会很轰动，那会很轰动。我知道，我们既兴奋又紧张。
You and your sister have a production company together, is that true?
Called Llewellyn Pictures.
Oh, that's fun.
That's fun.
After our late dog.
Aw.
We'll be right back.
Back to the show.
威尔对二战了解很多。我们涵盖的是战争的哪个部分，在哪个国家？是法国抵抗运动。哦，当然。哦，当然。一支烟。我拿一支烟。我去杀几个纳粹。
I have a dumb, dumb question.
Have you guys, other than the stuff when you were kids, have you done anything as a
adults together in a film?
No, and it's about to happen in a month.
No way, no way.
What is it?
Yes, we have never read a line together, never.
We visited each other on set, but we do not, we have never done that, never been on
我在那个时间旁边留下一个装有炸药的袋子。我们还在选角。我们还在选角。所以如果你想给我们试镜，你可以。我很乐意寄去录像带。那太棒了。那太好了。我很高兴你们在做那个。
camera together other than, you know, me playing her young, but we're obviously not together.
And so, yeah, we're doing The Nightingale, which is a best-selling book by Kristen Hanna,
and we're playing sisters in that.
It's a sister story in World War II.
Wow.
Wow, that's so cool.
That'll be huge, that'll be huge.
I know, and we're excited and nervous.
那太酷了。你一定，你紧张吗？你兴奋吗？你是以上皆是吗？我们是，我想我们是以上皆是。我想这也是一点点踏入未知领域。和我们俩都合作过的人说，我们的工作方式非常不同。我们在片场非常不同。
Will knows a lot about World War II.
What portion of the war are we covering in what country?
It's the French resistance.
Oh, sure.
One cigarette.
It's the best I take a cigarette.
I go and I kill some Nazis.
哦，酷。是的。这不是坏事，只是我们的能量非常不同。你们每天都聊天吗？每一天。我们好得不可思议，是的。真的吗？我们一起玩，我们住得很近。
I leave a bag with explosives next to that time.
We're still casting.
So if you want to give us an audition, you can.
I'd love to send in the tape.
How, that's excellent.
That's so great.
I'm so happy that you guys are doing that.
我喜欢那样。我喜欢那样。但等等，我们刚才跳过了你的新剧。我知道。所以告诉我们关于……烦恼。烦恼。那里没有省略号。
That's so cool.
You must be, are you nervous?
Are you excited?
Are you all of the above?
We are, I think we're all of the above.
I think it's also stepping into the unknown a little bit.
And people who have worked with both of us say that we work in a very different way.
That we're extremely different on set.
它直接就过去了。所以是你和出色的米歇尔·菲佛，我们崇拜她。我们崇拜米歇尔。威尔刚和她合作过。我爱她。我爱米歇尔。她太棒了。是的，她是最好的。
Oh, cool.
Yeah.
It's not a bad thing, but just that our energy is very different.
Do you guys talk every single day?
Every day.
We are unbelievably close, yeah.
Really?
We hang out, we live close to each other.
还有她的丈夫，大卫，对吧？是的，大卫是，他写了这部剧。哦，酷。我是说，他们以前从未合作过。他们从来没有。哇。这是第一次。哇。
I love that.
But wait, we scooted right past your new show.
I know.
So tell us about...
Troubles.
There's no ellipses there.
在这部剧里。是的。哇。很多人在合作，他们以前从未合作过。所以，是的，所以是你和米歇尔，还有。尼克·奥弗曼。尼克·奥弗曼。伟大的尼克·奥弗曼。
It just goes right through.
So it's you and the wonderful Michelle Pfeiffer, whom we adore.
We adore Michelle.
That Will just worked with.
I love her.
I love Michelle.
She's amazing.
Yeah, she's the best.
太棒了。是的。伟大的尼克·奥弗曼。是的。格雷格·金尼尔。伟大的格雷格·金尼尔。伟大的格雷格·金尼尔。前几天有人。有人，你知道，一个不知名的
And her husband, David, right?
Yes, David is the, he wrote the show.
Oh, cool.
I mean, they've never worked together before.
They've never.
Wow.
This is the first time.
妮可·基德曼。妮可·基德曼。我们支持她。不，是的，妮可·基德曼。让我盯着她看。天哪。天哪。该死。那太棒了。你一定对这部剧感到非常兴奋。每个人都在谈论它有多棒。哦，那太好了。不，我真的很兴奋。它也算是一个，我是说，我也是《凯瑟琳大帝》的制片人，而且我。哦，你是吗？我是。所以那是我第一次真正看到幕后，比如，你知道，第一次推销一部剧。那是我第一次做那个。但这个，《玛戈》真的感觉是从零开始，因为它是，我在书出版前就读了它。所以我不得不和鲁比谈，
In this show.
Yes.
Whoa.
A lot of people working together who've never worked together.
So it's, yeah, so it's, it's you and Michelle and.
Nick Offerman.
The great Nick Offerman.
她写了那本书。她必须得到，你知道，这是一个真正的过程。然后我们和A24、大卫以及所有人，还有演员阵容组建了这个动态团队。然后我们出去了，真的很努力地推销它。所以它感觉绝对是这种合作，但有些事情我，我不知道，
Wonderful.
Yeah.
Great Nick Conier.
Yes.
Greg Kinnear.
The great, Greg Kinnear.
some the other day. Someone, you know, an unknown
我参与度很高，而且我爱这个角色。好吧，是的，我以为你要说，我肯定你为它感到自豪，那种从一开始就在那里并一路引导它的过程。你有责任感吗？我不是负面意思，但你觉得这种，就像，以那种方式对它真正的关心吗？
Nicole Kidman. Nicole Kidman.
We're rooting for her. No, yeah, Nicole Kidman.
Let me just keep your eye on her.
Jesus. Jesus. Holy shit.
That's so great. You must be so excited about the show.
Everybody's talking about how great it is.
Oh, that's so nice. No, I really am.
It was also kind of one that, I mean, I was a producer on the
是的，我想你确实会感到这种关心，而且你会感到一点压力，因为你，这有点像暴露你的内心，你希望那是所有东西。我是说，你希望人们，你希望人们喜欢它，显然。我是说，一部剧拍摄也需要很多时间。是的，是的。
grade as well and I.
Oh, you were? I was. I was. So that was kind of the first time I actually got to see
behind the scenes of like, you know,
pitching a show for the first time.
That was the first time I did it on that.
But this, Margo truly feels like from the ground up
because it was, I read the book before it was published.
And so I had to talk to Ruffy,
你喜欢那种更长的参与度吗？事实是你从推销、开发、前期制作到后期制作都参与其中，而不仅仅是拍摄部分？或者经历过几次之后，你会想，是的，也许我会在中间做几个表演工作，就像打一枪换一个地方，进去，出来。你做吗，或者你愿意
who wrote the book.
And she had to get, you know, it was a real process.
And then we assembled this, like, dynamic team
with 824 and David and all, and the cast.
And then we went out.
and really pitched it hard.
And so it just feels like it's definitely this collaboration,
but something that I'm, I don't know,
你喜欢从头到尾坚持一个项目并做完整件事吗？我现在有点尝到甜头了。我觉得我喜欢那种权力。我想还有一些东西在于成为。那太搞笑了。是的。成为一名童星，
I'm very involved in, and I love this character.
Well, yeah, I thought you're going to say,
I'm sure you're very proud of it,
that process of being there right from the get-go
and sort of shepherding it all the way through.
Do you feel responsibility?
I don't mean that in a negative way,
but do you feel like this, like, real care for it in that way?
我想你也花了很多时间。不是说，我是说，我们不是在唠叨这个，但它确实是我的起源故事，但是，你知道，作为一个观察者，就像你被选为观察成年人做有趣事情的观察者。而且你也在片场。我想我现在已经到了一个地方，
Yeah, I think you do feel,
this care and you feel a little bit of pressure
because you, it's kind of like exposing
your heart and you hope that that's with everything.
I mean, and you hope that people,
you hope that people like it, obviously.
I mean, a show also takes so much time to film too.
Yeah, yeah.
我感觉非常，就像，在自己身上，我想这也来自于，好吧，就像，尊重长辈，你不想表现得像，我知道得太多，我知道得比你多，但确实有一个点，我想现在我可以说了，好吧，不，也许我确实知道，因为我从两岁起就在片场了。
Do you like that longer involvement, the fact that you're involved with it
during pitching and developing and pre-production
and post-production aside from just the filming part of it?
Or having gone through that a couple of times now,
you're like, yeah, maybe I'll just do like
a couple of acting gigs in between
just sort of hit and run, get in, get out.
Do you do or would you like to
所以我见过很多。是的，你有所有这些经验。你知道你在说什么。就像，你知道，如何处理危机或如何解决问题，以及什么，就像，我见过，而且我真的是在工作中学习的。就像，我没去过表演学校什么的。所以我从这些导演身上学习，他们每个人工作的方式都大不相同。
do you like staying with a project from start to finish
and doing the whole thing?
I kind of got a taste for it now.
I feel like I like the power.
I think there's something in also being.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
Being like a child actor,
所以我变得非常灵活。你必须这样，你知道，所以我现在可以把这些运用到制作过程中，我喜欢那样。以一种毫不妥协的方式，你在桌子旁有一席之地，桌子旁的合法性。所以当你插话时，你不必说，噢，抱歉，打扰一下，我有个主意。我绝对过去那样做过，你知道。而我现在不需要那么做了。我真的很喜欢后期制作。
I think you also spend a lot of time.
not that, I mean, we're not harping on this,
but it is like my origin story,
but, you know, being an observer,
like you're cast as the observer
who watches the adults do the fun things.
And you're also on set.
I think I've gotten to a place now
我喜欢剪辑。是的，是的。好吧，那么我下一个最喜欢的问题总是，你看到你的未来也有导演工作吗，既然你有这么多片场经验。我知道。这太陈词滥调了。
where I feel very, like, in myself,
where I think it also comes from,
okay, like, respect your elders
and you don't want to be like,
I know too much,
I know more than you, but there does come a point,
and I think now that I can say, well, no, maybe I do,
because I've been on set since I was two.
每个人都说，噢，是的，我想成为一名导演。是的，但我认为每个人都想，我是说，但在任何职业中，你都想要那种晋升。你想要能够使用你一直在学习的东西，而这通常存在于你之上的工作中。你不断地学习更多关于这个过程的知识。所以对于导演来说，它允许你使用你一直在观察、吸收和观察的一切。是的，我梦想那个很久了，甚至从我年轻时起。
So I've seen a lot.
Yeah, you've got all this experience.
You know what you're talking about.
Like, you know, how to a crisis or how to problem solve
and what, like, I've seen, and I really learned on the job.
Like, I didn't go to acting school or anything.
So I was learning from these directors,
and they all worked in this vastly different way.
而且我会写很多。我现在没那么做了。但那是，你知道，我在学校里一直最喜欢的，想出故事和事情。所以我知道那在我的未来，但我不认为它在我的近期未来。它在那里。是的。好吧，说到你的近期未来，你不工作的时候在做什么？我是说，你一直在工作。
So I became very malleable.
you had to be, you know, and so I get to put that into the producing process now,
and I like that.
In an unapologetic way, you have a seat at the table, legitimacy of the table.
So when you chime in, you don't have to say, oh, sorry, excuse me, I've got an idea.
I definitely used to do that, you know.
And I don't so much have to anymore.
I really like the post-production.
是的。是的，今年，今年和去年真的很疯狂。但我一直知道我是个怪胎。我喜欢数字5。所以我也喜欢。那是我的幸运数字。那是我的幸运数字。是的。
I love editing.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Well, then my next favorite question always is,
do you see directing in your future as well,
since you've got so much set experience.
I know.
It's such a cliche.
而且我们，我只是觉得2025年一直是我计划的。就像，我15岁时做了一些事情，就像因为数字5。就像，我计划了很多事情。为什么是5？为什么是5？我觉得它是一个偶数，尽管它是一个奇数。因为它在所有数字的中间。就像1到10。
Everyone's like, oh, yeah, I want to be a director.
Yeah, but I think everybody wants to, I mean,
but in any occupation, you want that promotion.
You want to be able to use what you've been learning,
and that usually lives in the job that's just above you.
You're constantly learning more about the process.
And so with directing, it allows you to use everything you've been obviously taking a look at and absorbing and observing.
Yeah, I've dreamed about that for a long time, even since I was young.
那是一个很小的吗？我喜欢那个。是的。我喜欢那个。我也喜欢数字5，值得一提。我喜欢它。你喜欢什么，肖恩？你喜欢什么？
And I would write a lot.
I don't so much do it as much anymore.
But it was, you know, my favorite always in school and coming up with stories and things.
And so I know that that's in my future, but I don't think it's in my near future.
It's there.
Yeah.
Well, speaking about your near future, what are you doing when you're not?
I mean, you're constantly working.
我喜欢3。我喜欢3。是的，我也挺喜欢3的。那是表亲。是的。那么，是的，肖恩是什么。我不知道我是否回答了，就像，我刚才到底说了什么。你问了我一个问题。
Yeah.
Yeah, this year's been, this year and last year was really insane.
But I always knew that I'm such a freak.
I love the number five.
And so I do too.
That's my favorite number.
It's my favorite number.
Yeah.
我心想，是的。我真的很喜欢数字5。怪胎。他说的是什么。还有我姐姐和她的朋友克洛伊，她们会听这个。这就是为什么我，我的屁股都紧绷了。我心想，因为她们太喜欢这个节目了。
And we, I just felt like 2025 was always, I planned.
Like, I did certain things when I was 15, like because the number five.
Like, I planned a lot of stuff.
Why five?
I feel like it's an even number, although it's an odd.
Because it's in the middle of all the numbers.
Like one to ten.
哇，我们爱你们。我刚才和达科塔聊过。她说，你马上就要做“聪明听”了。但她实际上，我当时说，我很紧张。她说，不，这只是一次谈话。是的，我们只是在闲逛。我们都在闲逛。好吧，向她们俩问好。
Is that a very small?
I like that.
Yeah.
I like the number five too for what it's worth.
I love it.
What do you like, Sean?
What do you like?
是的。但肖恩说的是，关于未来，就像，你工作得太多了。你，你有没有在未来为自己留出一些非工作时间？你知道，我想我得在这方面做得更好，但我也不是，我不认为我太，我只是太，我不想，我想在这一刻做完所有事情。你和格斯喜欢做什么？你最喜欢做什么？你最喜欢特雷西的是什么？
I like three.
Yeah, I kind of like three too.
That's a cousin.
Yeah.
So then, yeah, what Sean was.
I don't know if I even answered like, what the heck did I just say.
You asked me a question.
那是你的男朋友。是的，那是我的男朋友特雷西。我们喜欢去旅行。他实际上一直是一个非常好的人，天哪，他真是，好吧，我们在很多方面都很相似，因为他也是极其外向的，但他极其脚踏实地，能够真正让我脚踏实地，而且他会为我留出时间，我心想，我甚至没意识到，但就像，好吧，我们要过这个周末，或者我们要开车去圣巴巴拉，我们要安排这次旅行，而且这只是，我不擅长组织
I'm like, yes.
I really like the number five.
Weirdo.
What he was saying like.
And my sister.
and her friend, Chloe, they are going to listen to this.
That's why I'm like, my butt cheeks are like clenched.
I'm like, because they love this show so much.
我不，我擅长在我的，就像在工作安排方面，那样我非常在行，而且那是我唯一想的事情，所以然后他会把我转过来，也去想那些其他事情。这是一个非常壮观的评论。我们称他们为锚。斯科蒂是我的锚。每个人都需要一个锚。是的，我们真的是一个好的。
Wow, we love you guys.
And I talked to Dakota right before.
She's like, you're about to do smart listen.
But she actually, I was like, I'm nervous.
She's like, no, it's just a conversation.
Yeah, we're just hanging out.
We're all just hanging out.
Well, hello to them both.
我是说，该死的没评论。是的。我是说，他在谈论。这很好。斯科特是我的锚。每个人都需要一个锚。我在尝试。我在尝试那样做。
Yeah.
But what Sean was saying, like, about the future, like, you're working so much.
What do you, do you, have you carved out some, like, non-work time in your future?
You know, I guess I got to get better at doing that, but also I'm not, I don't think I'm too,
I'm just so, I don't, I want to do it all in this moment.
What do you and Gus like to do?
What's your favorite thing to do?
What's your favorite for Tracy?
但我们也极其有野心，我们俩都是。所以我认为这也是，我心想，是的，你去忙你的，我去忙我的。就像，你不需要。你不必跟着我到片场。就像，来探班，但也要，你知道，你不需要，我不需要你只是，就像，坐在拖车里。这就像，我知道那很无聊，你知道？
That's your boyfriend.
Yes, that's my boyfriend for Tracy.
We love going on trips.
He has actually been a really nice, gosh, he is such, well, we're very similar in a lot of ways
because he's also extremely extroverted, but he's extremely grounded and is able to
to really ground me and also he kind of carves out the time for me and I'm like I don't even
realize it but like okay let's we're going to do this weekend away or we're going to drive to
Santa Barbara we're going to set up this trip and and it's just not I'm not great at organizing
是的，是的，是的。他不想那样做。所以我们是，你知道，我们是。他是一个好人，我这些年来见过你的格斯几次。他是一个真正的好人，非常好的人。是的。好吧，那太棒了。所以你做什么，就像，在今天这样的一天？
I don't and I'm good at organizing in my like with scheduling with work like that I'm very on it
and that's kind of all I think about and so then he
kind of turns me away to also think about those other things.
It's a really, it's a spectacular comment.
We call them anchors.
Scottie's my anchor.
Everybody needs an anchor.
Yeah, we really are a good.
对。在所有这些事情中，你正在做，你正在，我是说，现在，你一直在做媒体宣传、放映、见面会，并准备工作和准备，等等等等，你今天做什么？如果你有下午，你今天做什么？什么让你高兴为你自己留出时间？
I mean, fucking no comment.
Yeah.
I mean, he's talking about.
It's good.
Scott is my anchor.
Everybody needs an anchor.
I'm trying.
I'm trying to do that.
天哪，好吧，你说它有起伏。就像，我进入某种模式，就像，好吧，现在我喜欢锻炼或者我喜欢做这个。所以我去普拉提做这个。然后对我来说就是全有或全无。所以我现在根本不在那个阶段。那艺术和手工之类的东西呢？我有一个烹饪的东西。
But also we're extremely ambitious like both of us.
And so I think it's also, I'm like, yeah, you go do your thing
and I go do mine.
It's like, you don't got it.
You don't have to come follow me to set.
Like, come and visit, but also, you know,
you don't, I don't need you just, like, sitting in the trailer.
It's like, I know that's boring, you know?
是的，这就是我说的。是的，我喜欢绘画和素描，就像那在我心里。是的。但它不是，我得做得更多。就像我想到它。我心想，你知道吗？如果我有一个绘画室什么的，我会非常高兴。绝对。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He doesn't want to do that.
So we're, you know, we're.
He's a nice, I've met your Gus a few times over the years.
He's a real nice, really nice guy.
Yeah.
Well, that's great.
So what do you do, like, on a day like today?
但它也感觉太难了。是的，绝对。我心想，你知道，我的梦想是，艾尔，我的梦想是有人来。顺便说一句，我做过一次。我让某人过来。这是多年前和一些朋友一起。我们完全嗨了。我们都抽了大麻。
Right.
In midst all this stuff, you're doing, you're, I mean, right now,
you're constantly doing press and screenings and meet and greets
and getting ready.
to work and prepping and blah, blah, blah, what do you do today?
What do you do today if you have the afternoon?
Like, what are you going to do?
What makes you happy to carve out for you?
然后一个女人带着七台缝纫机过来，我们都做了枕头。对。就像嗨得不行，我们只是做了枕头。而且就像那是我们需要做的，对吧？我们需要有人过来教我们，就像，嘿，我想画画。你能帮我准备一些东西，然后我就画画吗？
Gosh, well, you say it ebbs and flows.
Like, I get into modes of, like, okay, now I'm like, I love working out or I love doing
this.
So I'm going to go to Pilates and do this.
And then it's like all or nothing for me.
So I'm not in that phase right now at all.
What about like arts and crafts stuff?
I have a cooking thing.
然后我们就完成了。然后我们就做了。看，如果别人为我准备好，我听起来就像如果它为我准备好了，就像，好吧，你得去这个班，然后我会做，因为我也感觉，我心想，噢不，我不想放那个老师鸽子。那是对的。
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
Yes, I love painting and drawing and like that is in me.
Yeah.
But it's not, I got to do it more.
Like I think about it.
I'm like, you know what?
If I had like a painting room or something, I would be so happy.
Absolutely.
你知道，所以我心想，有一个义务。但如果只是我一个人，那么我就坐在电脑前看《叛徒》。一样。给你。看过每一季的每一集。我正在看，好吧，显然我们现在在看那一个。有一个英国或国内的。对吧？
But it also feels too hard.
Yes, absolutely.
I'm like, you know, my dream is, Elle, my dream is to have somebody come.
By the way, I did this once.
I had somebody come over.
This is years and years and years ago with some friends.
We got totally stone.
We all smoked pot.
有很多。有一个新西兰或澳大利亚什么的。是的。英语的是第一个吗？是的，英语的是第一个。这就像一个幸存者类型的东西，对吧？是的。是的，它就像黑手党。
And then some woman came over with seven sewing machines
and we all made pillows.
Right.
Like stoned out of our mind and we just made pillows.
And like that's what we need to do, right?
We need to have somebody come over to teach us like,
hey, I want to paint.
Can you just set some stuff up for me and I'll paint?
是的。记得我们过去常玩那个，杰伊？当然，是的，你是一个伟大的领导者。是的，我很好奇你们中是否有人看它。我是说，我希望罗伯赢。我也希望罗伯赢，因为他太聪明了。我知道，而且我总是希望叛徒赢。是的，总是，是的。
And then we're done.
And then we did it.
See, if someone else sets it up for me,
I sound like if it's set up for me,
it's like, okay, you've got to go to this class,
then I will do it because I feel also,
I'm like, oh no, I don't want to stand up that teacher.
That's right.
我总是那样。我也刚开始看名人英国版，我知道我有点晚了。我喜欢它。但你知道谁赢了吗？不。好吧，我不会。你有猜测吗？你有猜测吗？
You know, so I'm like, there's an obligation.
But if it's just me alone, then I sit on my computer and I watch traitors.
Same.
There you go.
Seen every episode of every iteration.
I'm watching so, well, obviously we're watching the one now.
There's a British or domestic one.
Right?
看，我觉得每个人都很快就发现了他们。是的，是的，是的。看不出来。我是说，凯特，我喜欢凯特，很多。是的，凯特很棒。所以她可能，我觉得，还有艾伦，我爱，我爱乔纳森，我爱他们，但我只是不，他们似乎都在他们身上，除非他们把特定的人弄出去。我觉得凯特和艾伦可能会走。这是一个非常令人满意的结局。哦，好的。好的。是的，我妈妈也看它，她说，你会喜欢这个的。她说，这是一个伟大的事情，是的。但我喜欢真人秀。所以我只是花，我心想，好吧，我坐着。我家里也有电视。我不打开它们。我只在电脑上看。
There's a lot.
There's a New Zealand or Australian or whatever.
Yeah.
Was the English one the first one?
Yeah, the English one was the first one.
This is like a survivor type of thing, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, it's like mafia.
嗯。所以它们只是装饰品吗？是的。我字面上，我不，它们不需要在这里。这太奇怪了。而且我有一台又重又旧的巨大电脑，我就是无法摆脱它。但屏幕太大了。我现在就在上面。而且就像今天早上的技术检查，我心想，伙计们，我不知道你们发送的这些电线中的任何一个。很少有嘉宾准时。这是一个准时的好嘉宾。一切都解决了。当我们在这里暂停时，威尔，你想回到肖恩的枕头派对吗？我想。仅视觉效果。
Yeah.
Remember we used to play that, Jay?
Sure, yeah, you're a great leader.
Yeah, I was wondering if any of you all watch it.
I mean, I want Rob to win.
I want Rob to win too because he's so clever.
I know, and I always want the traders to win.
Yeah, always, yeah.
你的。是的，七台缝纫机和一个炸弹。你，一群嗨了的中年娱乐类型的人在一个美丽的豪宅里。这是我一直以来想的一切。太有趣了。伙计们，我们应该做。我甚至没开玩笑。真的很有趣。
I'm always like that.
I also just started the Celebrity UK, which I know is I'm a little late too.
I'm loving it.
But do you know who won that?
No.
Okay, I won't.
Do you have a guess?
确保，是的，我很好，我确定，财富的从不。那是问题所在。来吧，沃尔米克枕头。我们会做的。我们会做的。艾尔，听着，你真是个快乐。老实说。只是一个快乐，艾尔。
See, I feel like everyone is on to them really quickly.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
can't see that. I mean, Cat, I like Cat, a lot. Yeah, Cat's great. So she possibly, I feel like,
and Alan, I love, I love Jonathan, I love them, but I just don't, they're all seem to be on them
unless they get particular people out. I think Cat and Alan could go. It's a very satisfying ending.
Oh, good. Okay, good. Yeah, my mom watches it too, and she was like, you're going to love this.
She was like, it's a great thing, yeah. But I love reality TV. So I just spend, I'm like, okay, I sit. I also have TVs in my
home. I don't turn them on. I only watch on my computer.
你太棒了。很高兴有你。我是说，你只是，你是一个令人印象深刻的演员，你做了这么多令人惊奇的事情。很高兴你的新剧。玛戈有钱财烦恼。是的，我会说。钱。来吧。
Huh. So they're just decoration or?
Yeah. I literally, I don't, they don't need to be here. It's so weird. And I have a giant
computer that is heavy and old and I just can't get rid of it. But the screen is so big. I'm
on it right now. And like the tech check this morning, I was like, guys, I don't know any of these
wires you sent. Very rarely is a guest on time. It's a good on time. It all worked out.
While we're paused here, Will, did you want to double back on Sean's pillow party at all?
I did.
The visual alone.
麻烦。烦恼。钱。暂停，烦恼。暂停，烦恼。听着，我们只是，这只是一个伟大的，你只是带来如此积极，你太棒了，我们只是如此粉丝。我可以和你聊一整天。一整天。谢谢，上帝，我感觉一样。我感觉一样。而且我最喜欢的部分，我只是要说这个，
Your.
Yeah, seven sewing machines and a bomb.
You, a bunch of stoned middle-aged entertainment types in a beautiful Hollywood mansion.
It's everything I ever always thought.
It was so fun.
You guys, we should do it.
I'm not even kidding.
It's really fun.
因为码头上最好的部分是你担心点冲浪和草坪太奢侈是令人难以置信的。好吧，但我没有。还有杰森说，噢，我们那个时间长了吗？我是说，那是最好的。所以当我在，当我需要一个接我的时候，就像，我转。我在TikTok上看那个，就像，而且我想很多人都这样做。我想这是一件事，但它非常清楚。小口。是的，是的。好吧，谢谢你，亲爱的。
Make sure to, yeah, I'm good, I'm sure, the wealth of never.
That's the issue.
Come on, Walmick pillows.
We'll do it.
Elle, listen, you are such a delight.
Honestly.
Just a delight, Elle.
好吧，谢谢你做这个。我们爱你，艾尔。谢谢，艾尔。谢谢。谢谢。再见，伙计们。这太有趣了。再见，再见，再见，再见，再见。谢谢你邀请我。你得到了。谢谢。枕头派对。哦，肖恩。
You are amazing.
So happy to have you.
I mean, you're just, you're such an impressive actor, and you've done so many amazing things.
So happy for your new show.
Margo's got money troubles.
Yes, I'll say.
Money.
Come on.
是的。我是说，为什么是那样？嘿，伙计们，我们今晚应该做什么？你知道，我们有这一大袋大麻，你觉得呢？我们应该疯狂一点，给那个有缝纫机的女孩打电话吗？是的。是的。听起来很甜，兄弟。
Trouble.
Troubles.
Money.
Pause, troubles.
Listen, we're just, it's just such a great, you just bring such positivity and you're amazing
and we're just such fans. I could talk to you all day long. All day.
Thank you, God, I feel the same. I feel the same. And my favorite part, I just got to say this,
你记得她的号码吗？嗯哼。是的。我们应该用缝纫机做什么？让我们做枕头。是的，我们都做了枕头。这就是为什么我从不。嘿，你知道，那会很酷。
because the best part on the dock is when you're worried that ordering the surf and turf is too
extravagant is unbelievable. Well, but I didn't. And Jason going, oh, did we go long on that?
I mean, that's the best.
So when I'm in, when I need a pick me up, like, I turn.
I watch that on TikTok, like, and I think a lot of people do.
I think it is a thing, but it's freaking clear.
Little bites. Yeah, yeah.
Well, thank you, my dear.
我们应该去。我是皮特。这是在晚上，对吧？是的，是的。你知道我们应该做什么吗？我们应该去推销名人血汗工厂，对吧？我们都做枕头。所以那是一个真正的快乐。我是说，多么美妙的人类。
All right, thanks for doing this.
We love you, Al.
Thank you, Al. Thank you.
Thank you. Bye, guys. This was so fun.
Bye, bye, bye, bye, bye. Thank you for having me on.
You got it. Thanks.
Pillow party.
Oh, Sean.
我印象深刻。她是一个美妙的人类。她有很棒的能量。她总是。她总是积极和酷。她正如我一直希望的那样。是的，然后只是做所有这些令人难以置信的工作，不断做不同的事情。
Yeah.
I mean, why was that?
Hey, guys, what should we do tonight?
You know, we got all this big bag of weed and what do you think?
Should we just go crazy and call that gal with the sewing machines?
Yeah.
That sounds sweet, bro.
是啊。我的意思是，为什么会那样？嘿，伙计们，我们今晚该干点什么？你知道，我们有这一大袋大麻，你们觉得呢？我们要不要疯狂一下，给那个有缝纫机的姑娘打个电话？好啊。好啊。听起来太棒了，兄弟。
Do you remember her number?
Uh-huh.
Yeah.
And what should we do with the sewing machine?
Let's make pillows.
Yeah, we all made pillows.
This is why I never.
Hey, you know, it would be really cool.
你还记得她的号码吗？嗯哼。记得。那我们拿缝纫机做什么呢？我们来做枕头吧。是啊，我们都做了枕头。这就是为什么我从来不。嘿，你知道吗，那会非常酷。
We should go and.
I'm Pitt. This is on the night, right?
Yeah, yeah.
You know what we should do?
We should go pitch celebrity sweatshop, right?
We all make pillows.
So that was a real delight.
I mean, what a wonderful human being.
我们应该去。我是皮特。这是在晚上，对吧？是啊，是啊。你知道我们该做什么吗？我们应该去推销名人血汗工厂，对吧？我们都做枕头。所以那真是一次愉快的经历。我的意思是，她真是个了不起的人。
I'm so impressed.
She is a wonderful human being.
She's got great energy.
She's always.
She's always just positive and cool.
She was exactly as I'd always hoped she would be.
Yeah, and then just does all this incredible work,
constantly doing different stuff.
我印象非常深刻。她确实是个了不起的人。她精力充沛。她总是。她总是那么积极和酷。她完全是我一直希望她成为的样子。是啊，而且她还做了所有这些不可思议的工作，一直在做各种不同的事情。
I mean, it's just amazing.
She's got one of the new, she's in one of the new, what are those,
you know the thing that I'm talking about.
Oh, here he comes.
No, no, I'm not.
It's a hunger game.
She's in the new Hunger Games as well.
Oh, she is?
我的意思是，这太棒了。她参演了新的，她在新的，那叫什么来着，你知道我在说什么。哦，他来了。不，不，我不是。那是饥饿游戏。她也参演了新的《饥饿游戏》。哦，是吗？
Yeah.
She's on fire.
She's amazing.
Oh, she's totally on fire.
And I can't wait to see you.
Markos got money troubles.
I know that book was really good.
I love that you forgot.
是的。她现在火得不行。她太棒了。哦，她确实火得一塌糊涂。我迫不及待想见到你。马科斯有经济困难。我知道那本书真的很棒。我喜欢你竟然忘了这件事。
Oh, I think I read that book.
I know.
What do you read a book in an hour or something like that?
No, I read like three or four in my life.
That was one of them.
And so even though you forgot the one of the three.
I know.
It takes me a month and a half to read a book.
哦，我想我读过那本书。我知道。你是一个小时读完一本书还是怎么的？不，我这辈子也就读过三四本。那本就是其中之一。所以即使你忘了那三本书中的一本。我知道。我读完一本书要花一个半月。
I'm not going to forget if I read a book.
It takes me a while.
Will, how long does it take you to read like an adult book?
Well, I've been reading a lot later.
Like the last two.
weeks, I'm on my fourth book in the last two weeks.
Wow.
Yeah.
如果我读过一本书，我是不会忘的。我读得比较慢。威尔，你读一本成人书籍需要多久？嗯，我最近读了很多。就像过去两周，我已经在读第四本书了。哇。是的。
When do you, when are you doing this?
At night, sometimes during the day, if I have timed down on the day for an hour or whatever,
so how many pages will you read before you knock off?
60 pages?
Depends on how tired I'm, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, but like that's a average.
Sometimes you get in 10, 15 pages and you're just, eyes are happy.
Right, right.
你是什么时候读的？晚上，有时在白天，如果我白天有一个小时左右的空闲时间，或者其他什么时间，那你睡觉前会读多少页？60页？取决于我有多累，是的，是的。是的，但这只是个平均数。有时读了10到15页，眼睛就受不了了。对，对。
But usually it's about a half hour reading and then you're sleeping?
Mm-hmm.
Uh-huh.
Yeah, and I do a lot of reading during the day, too, on my, like, sometimes.
Sometimes in the morning I'll wake up if I'm up early.
And you enjoy it.
You just enjoy reading.
I like reading about things I like to read about.
但通常是读半小时然后就睡觉了？嗯哼。啊哈。是的，我白天也读很多，有时。有时如果我起得早，早上醒来也会读。你很享受它。你只是喜欢阅读。我喜欢读我感兴趣的东西。
I get excited to.
But if you sent me a book about like, I don't know.
Like motorcycle driving.
Sure.
I don't know.
What would that be called?
Motorcycle would be more, but you know what it would be a good to read about would be
what?
我也很兴奋。但如果你给我一本关于，我不知道，比如摩托车驾驶的书。当然。我不知道。那叫什么？摩托车会更多，但你知道读什么会很好吗？读什么？
Bicycle.
Bicycle riding.
That was cheap.
That was good.
Bye.
自行车。骑自行车。这梗太烂了。不过挺好的。挺好的。再见。再见。再见。
Smart.
Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Rob Armjarf, Bennett Barbico, and Michael Grant Terry.
Smartless.
Smartless是由Rob Armjarf、Bennett Barbico和Michael Grant Terry 100%有机且手工制作的。Smartless。